bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pendant la suspension
des travaux du Sénat je vous propose de
voir ou de revoir les temps fort de la
dernière session parlementaire et place
ce matin à l'audition de Patrick Drai le
PDG d'Altis group un groupe qui comprend
notamment SFR Numéricable mais aussi de
nombreux médias comme li tion L'Express
RMC ou BFM TV la parole de Patrick Dar
est plutôt rare on l'a découvert dans
cette audition début juin sur de lui
fier de son parcours et sans filtre un
client qui me quitte ça fait mal au cœur
et au portefeuille a-t-il par exemple
affirmé il a également assumé ses 50
milliards de dettes actuelles qui
commencent à effrayer certains banquers
enfin il a balayé d'un revers de la main
les critiques sur son interventionnisme
dans les médias tout de suite donc
retour à l'audition de Patrick DA le PDG
d'Altis j'ouvre cette séance nous avons
vraiment le très grand plaisir et je le
disais tout à l'heure au président DRI
le grand honneur d'accueillir ce matin
pour la première fois ici Patrick dai
président d'altist Group comme vous le
savez il s'agit d'un grand groupe
multinational que vous avez fondé et qui
a son siège à Amsterdam depuis l'an
dernier et ce groupe rassemble les
opérateurs de télécommunication des
entreprises de communication et de
médias alors votre groupe se caractérise
ainsi par la diversité de ces activités
par son orientation marquée à
l'international sur trois continents
mais aussi par sa stratégie de
croissance externe très
poussée le groupe a réalisé plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros
d'acquisition depuis 2014 avec le rachat
de Portugal Télécom de Next radio TV ou
encore du 4e cableau opérateur américain
câbl vision et bien sûr SFR qui au sein
du nouveau groupe SFR Numéricable
constitue désormais le deuxème opérateur
national vous nous direz monsieur le
Président quelle est la stratégie
d'ensemble que vous poursuivez à travers
ces acquisitions si vous comptez
poursuivre ce cycle et quelle part vous
entendez réservver à l'Europe et à notre
pays en
particulier ces acquisitions se sont
majoritairement faites en recourant à
l'emprunt grâce au mécanisme du LBO cela
a permis à votre groupe de connaître une
très forte croissance ces derniers temps
mais il a également conduit un niveau
d'endettement très élevé vous pourrez
aussi nous éclairer monsieur le
Président sur la façon dont vous
entendez soutenir cet endettement dans
un contexte où il faudra investir
notamment dans le secteur des télécom
nous nous attarderons bien sûr sur ce
secteur qui a connu une reconfiguration
importante derrièrement avec le
rapprochement de Numéricable SFR au sein
de votre holding la montée en puissance
d'illatf et les tentatives de rachat
manqué de Bou Télécom tentative que vous
avez conduite pour l'une d'entre elles
en annonçant juin de l'année dernière
une offre d'achat public offre publique
d'achat pour 10 milliards d'euros vous
nous direz donc si vous voyez un avenir
à trois ou quatre opérateurs et s'il y a
selon vous une menace de la part de
grands opérateurs étrangers vous pourrez
nous faire part des perspectives de
croissance du secteur à la fois dans le
fix et le mobile avec la transition
progressive du marché vers le Très Haut
Débit nous serions intéressés de
connaître la stratégie de SFR
Numéricable sur chacun des deux types de
réseau et notamment ses ambitions dans
la 4G et dans la fibre sur le marchés
des particuliers mais aussi sur celui
très spécifique des entreprises dont on
ne parle pas
assez à ce sujet vous le savez sans
doute monsieur le Président l'arcepep a
donné jusqu'au 15 juin aux quatre
opérateurs français pour lui soumettre
de nouveaux contrats concernant leurs
accords d'itinérance et de partage du
réseau le régulateur ATT des
propositions en vue de modifier
notamment le contrat d'itilérance entre
freemobil et orange d'une part et le
contrat de mutualisation et d'tinérance
entre Bou Télécom et SFR d'autre part
peut-être pourrez-vous également nous en
dire un mot voilà qu que un des sujets
que vous allez évoquer monsieur le
Président encore une fois je le redis
devant nos collègues nous sommes très
très heureux de pouvoir vous accueillir
aujourd'hui dans une maison dont vous
avais dit tout à l'heure que vous
l'aviez connu quand vous étiez élève à
l'X puisque les salons beaufan avit
accueilli un grand rassemblement de vos
congénères monsieur le Président
pardon oui alors une précision mes chers
collègues donc c'est une
réunion qui fait l'objet d'une vidéo
transmission comme vous l'avez remarqué
il y a maintenant des caméras qui sont
installé c'est la première fois Monsieur
Dr que généralement il fallait
s'installer dans une autre salle équipée
et cetera mais maintenant c'est notre
salle de réunion qui est équipée et donc
cette séance est retransmise par la
télévision
voilà merci monsieur le Président je
crois qu'il faut que j'appuie voilà
merci monsieur le Président euh mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs d'abord je suis
très ému et très heureux d'être devant
vous euh je crois que c'est une c'est
une logique une suite logique à
l'audition que j'avais eu à à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a de cela
quelques mois et pour moi ça me permet
de me remettre au contact avec le
terrain puisque vous représentez souvent
les les collectivités enfin pas souvent
mais toujours les collectivités locales
que
j'ai fréquenté très longuement dans les
années 90 à l'époque où j'ai rencontraé
les différents maires dont certains
étaient bien sûr sénateurs pour déployer
le câble dans ce beau pays à une époque
où évidemment le câble était
mort euh mon groupe comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le sénateur est un groupe
familial puisqu'il est contrôlé par par
moi-même on oublie souvent quand on
pense aux entreprises euh de voir si
c'est des hommes qui a derrière ou si ce
ne sont pas des hommes qui y a derrière
il a une grande différence entre un
groupe familial quel que soit sa taille
qu' soit deux salariés ou qu'il soit de
55000 salariés comme c'est notre cas et
un groupe qui n'est pas familial en
l'occurrence donc ce groupe est contrôlé
à hauteur de 60 % par par moi-même alors
il est basé aujourd'hui à Amsterdam il
est côté à la Bourse d'Amsterdam vous
aurez peut-être des questions sur ces
sujets je serai ravi d'y répondre euh ma
stratégie la stratégie de mon groupe ma
stratégie c'est la même chose euh est
très simple c'est euh d'investir dans
les meilleures infrastructures possibles
au monde dans les meilleurs pays du
monde que je considère comme étant les
meilleurs pays du monde pour les métiers
dans lesquels je veux m'impliquer afin
d'offrir à nos clients dont nous vivons
les meilleurs services en terme de
qualité en terme
d'innovation et en terme de
disponibilité comme vous le savez le
câble à l'origine c'était de la
télévision
analogique grâce à la concurrence du
satellite le câble s mis au numérique le
numérique c'était la télévision
numérique qui a permis d'offrir beaucoup
plus de chaînes de télévision à N à nos
clients on est ensuite passé au à
l'Internet qui est une façon de
communiquer au départ des simples
messages et qui aujourd'hui devient une
façon de communiquer de la vidéo et on
est passé aussi aux Télécom qui sont
devenus totalement ce qu'on appelle IP
c'estàdire Internet et donc on voit que
la convergence euh s faite au fil de
l'eau au fil de l'évolution des
technologies mais cette convergence euh
qui est une évidence pour tout le monde
ici dans la pièce en particulier nous
avons la télévision avec des caméras qui
sont ici IP teles que je les vois en
direct et qui est diffusé partout en
France
sur nos réseaux de façon numérique pour
certains chez nous et de façon internet
pour les réseaux ADSL qui ne peuvent pas
supporter les mêmes débits que les
nôtres bon donc cette convergence elle
est évidente aujourd'hui mais elle était
dans l'esprit de certains et en
particulier des chefs d'entreprise qui
ont créé leur entreprise dans les années
90 donc aujourd'hui moi je suis là pour
vous parler d'abord pour répondre à vos
questions bien évidemment mais aussi
pour vous parler de quelle est notre
vision pas pour les 10 dernières années
mais plutôt pour les 10 ans prochains
voir au-delà et en discutter avec vous
parce que je sais que pour vous très
très important d'équiper le le pays mais
aussi très important de faire en sorte
que nous ayons des modèles économiques
qui soient pérennes pour l'avenir à 10
20 ans et pas simplement pour préserver
le passé d' à 15 20 ans alors mon groupe
je l'ai construit forcément avec
l'argent des autres puisque quand je
suis né j'étais fils de prof euh je suis
né au Maroc j'ai trois épisodes dans ma
vie je suis né au Maroc j'ai fait mes
des études au lycé lioté l'un des
fleurons de l'éducation nationale à
l'étranger je suis rentré en France en
1978 j'ai intégré l'école
polytechnique j'ai fait l'armée très
formateur et j'ai fait ensuite Télécom
et à Télecom moi je na'ai pas souhaité
rejoindre l'opérateur historique France
tellécom même si j'en avais la
possibilité puisque j'étais pas trop mal
classé à la sortie de l'École
polytechnique j'ai préféré me mettre à
mon compte très rapidement en tout cas
et travailler dans le de la fibre
optique et comme je ne pouvais pas trop
travailler pour quelqu'un parce que je
j'avais du mal avec les visions à très
court terme mais j'étais plutôt à plus
long terme ben je me suis mis à mon
compte comme j'avais pas d'argent bah il
a bien fallu emprunter cet argent alors
je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui on me
critique sur mon niveau de dette mais je
dors beaucoup plus facilement avec 50
milliards de dettes qu'avec les premiers
50000 francs français de dette que j'ai
contracté quand j'ai créé mon entreprise
en 1981
11 pourquoi parce que quand j'ai créé
mon entreprise j'avais un projet mais
j'avais pas de clients j'avais pas
d'infrastructure j'avais pas de
collaborateurs et j'avais pas un franc
de chiffre d'affaires aujourd'hui je
n'ai plus un projet mais j'ai une
entreprise qui fait travailler environ
55000 personnes en interne plus des
dizaines de milliers auprès de nos
sous-traitants euh nous avons 60
millions de clients dans le monde dont
environ une vingtaine en France et nous
faisons euh supposer que les autorités
de New York nous donnent les
autorisations dans quelques jours et
nous ferons donc environ 24 milliards 25
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
cette année donc vous voyez qu'on a une
dette qui est à peu près égale à deux
fois notre chiffre d'affaires alors que
mes premiers 50000 francs ben c'était
l'infini mon chiffre d'affaires vu que
c'était zéro quand j'ai commencé
euh ce n'est pas contrairement à ce
qu'on pense des montages de type LBO que
nous faisons ce sont des montages de
type industriel dans lesquels
tout industriel à recours à la dette
donc dans lesquels nous avons recours à
la dette mais nous avons aussi recours à
notre capital puisque notre entreprise
aujourd'hui une valorisation sur le
marché de l'ordre de 70 milliards donc
c'est c'est logique
que de procéder à cette façonl mais ce
ne sont pas des LBO les LBO sont le
propre des fonds de private equity qui
ont recours à l'emprunt pour acheter des
sociétés en particulier pour les
revendre quelques années plus tard sur
les 23
ou 24 dernières années depuis que j'ai
créé ma société je n'ai jamais vendu la
moindre société à l'exception de
récemment au Portugal puisque comme j'ai
acheté Portugal Telecom j'ai été
contraint par le régulateur de revendre
le petit opérateur que j'avais constitué
avant mais donc à des exceptions près où
j'étais contraint de vendre pour des
questions réglementaires je n'ai jamais
vendu mon entreprise donc on peut pas
caractériser mes montages de type LBO
qui sont le
le je dirais la stratégie des des fonds
de privé d'investissement alors notre
stratégie c'est d'investir dans les
réseaux première chose donc vous le
constaterez nous sommes l'opérateur
probablement qui a le plus grand ratio
d'investissement sur chiffre d'affaires
euh j'ai repris SFR il y a de cela
maintenant un an et demi SFR un ratio de
l'ordre de 13 % de ses investissements
sur chiffres d'affaires il est
aujourd'hui dessus de 20 % euh très loin
devant la plupart de mes concurrents en
France et très loin devant la plupart de
mes concurrents dans le monde pourquoi
parce que c'est avec nos investissements
que nous préparons l'avenir alors dans
quoi nous investissons dans trois choses
et on fait et la stratégie est la même
dans tous les pays il y a pas de
différence entre nos investissements en
France nos investissements au Portugal
et bientôt nos investissements aux
États-Unis les investissements c'est
d'abord et avant tout dans le réseau
alors le réseau il y a deux parties il y
a la partie mobile puisque nous sommes
un opérateur convergent qui offront des
services fixes et mobiles donc la partie
mobile qui consiste à déployer de
nouveaux sites en France pour densifier
la couverture du du territoire national
et par ailleurs à implémenté les
nouvelles technologies aujourd'hui la 4G
nous avons ouvert récemment je crois
même la semaine dernière la 4G tris fois
plus et nous sommes les premier en la
matière et puis quand la 5G viendra ce
sera la 5G la 6G la 7g et ainsi de suite
et puis une autre un un autre
investissement qui est pour moi plus
fondamental mais le premier étant étant
réalisé également qui est la fibre
optique donc j'étais le premier à
déployer de la fibre optique euh j'ai
une avance très considérable sur
l'opérateur historique bon qui utilise
toutes sortes de subterfuge pour faire
comprendre que notre avance est un
retard et quant à mes concurrents plus
lointains euh nous avons une avance qui
qui qui est de plusieurs je pense années
voir dizaines
d'années alors une fois que nous avons
investi dans nos réseaux
le clientah lui c'est pas ça qu'il
achète il achète pas un abonnement à un
réseau il achète un abonnement à des
services donc nous investissons dans la
qualité de service la qualité de service
c'est quoi c'est quand un client veut
souscrire à nos offres le r le plus
rapidement possible regarderez les
statistiques nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans le réseau fibre en France
l'opérateur qui raccorde le plus vite
ses clients deè chose la qualité se juge
à au taux de résiliation de nos
clients nous avons fait baisser les taux
de résiliation sur SFR depuis plus d'un
an et demi maintenant de près de 50 %
donc ça c'est le jugement ultipe de
qualité donc nous investissons làd nous
investissons dans le service aux clients
et puis depuis quelques années je me
suis dit il faut investir également dans
le
contenu nous étions dépendants des
grands groupes de contenus
monsieur et donc nous souhaitons
investir davantage dans le contenu vous
l'avez vu nous avons lancé pas plus tard
qu'hier soir une nouvelle chaîne en
France qui est BFM sport euh nous avons
annoncé le lancement de BFM Paris euh on
a essayé les chaînes locales dans le
câble en France il y a très longtemps
c'était un grand échec pourquoi parce
que l'opérateur n'avait pas la la masse
critique pour pour subvenir à ces à ces
besoins locaux aujourd'hui nous avons
cette masse critique pour nous permettre
de lancer des chaînes locales beaucoup
plus riche beaucoup plus intéressante
pour pour nos clients donc voilà ça ce
sont les axes d'investissement
que nous privilégions le réseau la
qualité le contenu sont les trois axes
les plus importants pour pour mon groupe
alors quelle est la part de l'Europe la
part de la France la part du reste du
monde dans dans ma stratégie bah écoutez
la France je suis partie de la France
donc c'est une part
centrale il y a 6 ans en 200 maintenant
8 ans pardon en 2008 j'avais 100 % de
mes actifs qui étaient en France j'avais
Numéricable point final donc on a mis 5
6 ans à restructurer et à faire marcher
numéricable et à partir de 2008 même si
le grand public ne savait pas que ça
marchait encoreen est aperçu plutôt en
201223 je savais que l'entreprise était
dans les rails et donc j'ai dit
qu'est-ce que je fais maintenant j'ai
proposé à certains des acteurs existants
aujourd'hui une association qui a été
refusée donc j'ai dit bah autant se
développer à l'étranger puisqueon peut
plus faire grand-chose donc j'ai
commencé à investir en Belgique j'ai
commencé à investir dans les pays
voisins et puis dans les territoire
d'outrem les Antilles la Réunion et puis
au fur et à mesure cet investissement
est allé au-delà donc aujourd'hui nous
sommes présents en au Portugal nous
sommes le numéro alors dans chacun de
nos pays ma stratégie est simple c'est
d'être numéro 1 ou numéro 2 numéro 3 et
4 ça me plaît pas beaucoup donc numéro 1
numéro 2 un petit peu comme à l'école
hein donc en France on est numéro 2
après 25 ans de travail ça va être
difficile d'être numéro 1 mais pourquoi
pas par contre ça va être difficile de
passer numéro numéro 3 vu que le numéro
3 et 4 est très très loin en Israël nous
sommes numéro 2 pareil ça va être
difficile de passer numéro 3 et ça va
être très difficile de passer numéro 1
au Portugal on a la chance on est numéro
1 ça va être très difficile de passer
numéro 2 et récemment je me suis dit
parce que j'allais souvent aux
États-Unis et j'ai passé les premières
années de ma carrière aller très souvent
aux États-Unis parce que vous savez dans
les années 90 B le plan câble éant ce
qu'il était donc on avait dit c'est un
échec total moi je comprenais pas parce
que c'est un grand succès en Belgique
c'éit un grand succès aux États-Unis
donc j'étais j'allais souvent à
Bruxelles voir ce qui se passait et
j'allais souvent aux États-Unis voir ce
qui se passait et récemment dans lors
DEES de voyage aux États-Unis je me suis
dit ben grâce aux États-Unis j'ai pu
faire marcher le câble en France mais en
fait grâce à la France j'ai des
nouvelles façons de gérer parce que
comme les prix sont très très très bas
en France on a bien été obligé de
survivre dans cet environnement et je
suis allé voir combien il gagnait
d'argent aux États-Unis vu que les prix
sont beaucoup plus hauts j'ai dit mais
ils en gagnent beaucoup puisque les prix
sont beaucoup plus haut mais nous on
pourrait en gagner plus puisqueon s'est
géré avec des bout de chandelles en
réalité donc je me suis dit pourquoi ne
pas investir aux États-Unis alors vous
allez aux États-Unis en général on
arrive à New York et donc je me suis pas
trop pris la tête j'ai racheté le réseau
de New York j'aiétis beaucoup critiqué
cours de bourse qui était perturbé ça me
laisse de marbre hein de la même manière
que j'ai été beaucoup critiqué quand
j'ai commencé dans le câ tous les
copains disent mais tu es fous tu vas
perdre tout ton argent comme j'en avais
pas bon il y Ava pas de grand risque et
bien j'espère que dans quelques jours
nous clôturerons notre acquisition new
yorkaise on a clôturé notre première
acquisition qui est plus sur le Texas il
y a quelques il y a quelques mois et
mine de rien
euh si cela se passe bien cette année
nous serons presque aussi gros aux
États-Unis qu'en France pour vous donner
des ordres de grandeur en France nous
avons en valeur à peu près 30 % du
marché des télécoms français qui est un
marché de l'ordre de 38 milliards et
nous faisons 11
milliards et aux États-Unis nous allons
faire un peu plus de 9 milliards mais
nous n'aurons que 2 % du marché
alors bien évidemment la France c'est ma
priorité puisque c'est de là que je suis
parti mais en terme d'expansion de mon
groupe il va être difficile pour moi de
passer de 30 à 50 % en France donc même
si je travaille très très très bien je
vais peut-être passer 30 à 32 donc je
gagner 2 % de part de marché sur un
marché de 40 milliards ça fait 800
millions alors qu'aux États-Unis il me
paraît plus facile de baser de 2 à 10 et
les 8 % en question et bien c'est 40
milliards donc c'est tout le marché
français des télécom alors titre
d'information je sais pas si vous le
savez j'en suis assez fier
l'investissement que nous faisons aux
États-Unis c'est le plus gros
investissement jamais fait par un groupe
français aux États-Unis on a battu
Sanofi d'accord Sanofi c'était environ
17 milliards d'euros nous c'est plutôt
24 milliards d'euros aux États-Unis on
con est le plus gros investisseur
d'origine française aux États-Unis ça
j'en suis fier et je pense que quand
nous aons montré ce que nous savons
faire aux États-Unis c'est-à-dire dans
dans un an ou deux maximum on sera là
beaucoup plus fort comme groupe
international pour nous permettre de
continuer à nous à nous développer bien
sûr en France et aussi dans le le reste
du monde voilà autre point important
notre groupe même s'il est basé à
Amsterdam euh pour l'essentiel puisque
je connaissais beaucoup le le tissu
managérial français des chefs
d'entreprise pour l'essentiel les
patrons de mes filiales sont des
Français qui ont décidé de me rejoindre
et que j'ai expatrié à la tête de
chacune des entreprises ici ou là euh
dans le monde donc voilà donc notre
groupe a une stratégie très simple qui
est décidée d'une façon encore plus
simple par très peu de personnes et euh
d'une façon globale cette stratégie est
la même alors elle est adaptée
évidemment pays par pays en fonction des
réglementation locale des prix de marché
locaux qui sont pas les mêmes hein euh
on vend pas le produit au même prix en
France qu'au Portugal au Portugal qu'en
République Dominicaine et en République
Dominicaine qu'à New York en fonction
des pouvoirs d'achat et du tissu
concurrentiel
voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près tout
dit important à
dire quelle est notre clientèle cible ce
ne sont pas que les particuliers j'ai
décidé en 2008 de m'intéresser au marché
des entreprises et j'ai été le premier à
mettre sur le câble le marché des
entreprises j'ai racheté Completel en
2008 qui était le trème opérateur
français pour les à destination des
entreprises et completelle représenté au
sein du groupe Numéricable près de 30 %
de son chiffre d'affaires et aujourd'hui
la division entre prise chez SFR c'est
de l'ordre de 25 % de son chiffre
d'affaires on a une part de marché qui
est petite pour le moment mais que nous
souhaitons accroître au au fil de l'eau
mais qui est de l'ordre de 20 % voilà
alors si vous voulez bien bien merci
monsieur le Président alors maintenant
nous allons nous livrer au jeu des
questions et et des réponses alors la
règle est la suivante chaque intervenant
a le droit à 2 minutes et je suis le
gardien vigilant du chronomètre et
chacun s'ansloid d'ailleurs à respecter
le peu de autorité que j'ai encore gardé
alors je vous en remercie à l'avance mes
chers collègues je donne d'abord la
parole à Bruno Sido et ensuite à
ivrom merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur Draï d'être venu devant nous
pour présenter votre entreprise et
félicitations pour votre pour
l'ascenseur social et l'ascenseur
entrepreneurial et et votre réussite il
est vrai que vous avez été très bien
formé dans une très bonne école si j'ai
bien compris moi ma question je vous
parlerai pas finances et cetera je vous
parlerai terrain
euh il se trouve que de temps en temps
bon alors votre votre réseau mobile au
moins pour ce que j'en connais chez moi
fonctionne bien et je n'ai absolument
rien à dire de négatif et par contre sur
le réseau
fibre vous êtes certains départements
comme le mien ont fait des réseaux
d'initiativ publiqu et euh
naturellement on accueille les
opérateurs et vous êtes pas très pressé
de venir sur notre réseau semble-t-il
c'est dommage parce que ça créerait de
la concurrence et ça créerait donc de
l'activité donc vous avez vous utilisez
le réseau d'Orange et puis vous terminer
avec avec vos réseaux et de temps en
temps il y a des pannes des coups de
pelle malheureuses qui font que ça coupe
le réseau et il se trouve que quand on
compare le le service d'un de vos
concurrents historique et et vous vous
mettez 10 fois plus de temps à réparer
aux grand d'âes de vos abonnés et comme
je souhaite que toutes les entreprises
marchent bien je voudrais savoir
qu'est-ce que vous donc deux questions
venir dans le réseau d'initiativ publi
quand ils existent deuxièmement
l'entretien de vos réseaux quand vous en
avez merci Bruno Fido la parole est à
Yve Rome et ensuite à gérard César j'ai
oublié de présenter les personnes qui
accompagnent monsieur Dr voilà Monsieur
Arthur drefus qui est le directeur de la
communication et Régis turign qui est
secrétaire général du groupe SFR est
directeur de la réglementations et des
affaires institutionnelles bien donc la
paroleci monsieur Président j'ai bien
noté vos ambitions internationales qui
sont très vastes et très larges et cette
magnifique réussite mais permettez-moi
de m'intéresser davantage à à l'échelon
national quelles sont les conséquences
selon vous pour votre société de la
décision récente du ministère et de
l'arcepep sur la distinction entre câble
et
FTTH deuxème élément de la
question il semblerait que votre
stratégie de déploiement sur les
engagements intérieurement contractés
sur les zones amis ne soit pas à la
hauteur des engagements intérieurement
contractés 3è question euh selon vous
quels sont les principales causes de
l'échec de la reprise par Orange du la
société bug puisque vous aviez partie
lié notamment sur les liens qui vous
lise qui vous lit avec oui en matière de
téléphonie mobile
euh quel vous avez vous l'avez évoqué
mais j'ai bien noté la convergence que
vous portez sur à la fois les réseaux et
les médias et on voit bien quelle est
votre stratégie je souhaiterais que vous
nous en disiez un peu plus sur cette
volonté de lier médias et réseau et puis
j' on avait beaucoup de plaisir que vous
investissez sur la dimension entreprise
qui était jusqu'àalors trusté
exclusivement par
Orange dernière question je sais qu'il y
a quelques temps avant les évolutions
récentes vous étiez investi sur les
réseaux d'initiative publi j'ai eu la
chance de contracter avec votre société
pour un premier réseau d'initiative
publique celui de l'Oise j'aimerais
connaître quels sont vos stratégies en
la matière sur les autres réseaux
d'initiativ publique apparemment mon
collègue bounoido se plaint plutôt de
votre absence et moi moi je me peux que
me réjouir de votre présence même si
vous avez de mon point de vue des
efforts importants à conduire en matière
de commercialisation notamment pour le
raccordement des abonnés bien merci
vrome la parole est à gérard César
ensuite à Marcial Bourquin oui merci
monsieur le Président et merci et
félicitations monsieur le Président pour
votre action à la tête du groupe qui est
basé à Amsterdam nous allons bien noté
et la question que je voulais vous poser
c'est concernant le monde rural vous
vous avez semblé vous désintéressés du
monde rural c'est la question de Bruno
Sido et aujourd'hui dans le monde rural
nous souhaitons justement que beaucoup
de PME entreprises aussi les
particuliers puissent venir justement
être raccordés et quel est votre sens
votre initiative pour renforcer ce ce
monde rural car nous au niveau des
collectivités nous sommes tous des élus
locaux et nous avons des initiatives qui
sont prises avec le département en
particulier mais aussi euh ça coûte très
cher par rapport donc au comités de
commune et aux intercommunalités donc ma
question est êtes-vous intéressé par le
monde rural et surtout l'équipement du
monde rural en fibre optique bien merci
gérard César la parole est à Marcial
Bourquin et ensuite à Ladislas
ponyatovski
oui monsieur tri merci pour euh votre
présentation les élus qui sont ici sont
très attachés à la couverture du
territoire quel que soit les espaces
évidemment la partie la plus
intéressante et les parties les plus
urbaines il y a aussi les parties rural
mais aussi des villes moyennes qui
peuvent être détachées vous nous avez
montré votre capacité à à mettre en
place un véritable empire dans les
télécommunications et ça il faut vous le
reconnaître j'ai deux questions qui
peuvent être embêtantes pour vous euh
vous avez une holding au Luxembourg vous
êtes côté en bourse à
Amsterdam vous avez une participation
personnelle dans un paradis fiscal en
Angleterre vous êtes résident suisse
dans le Panama papers vous êtes vous
avez été cité est-ce que ça fait pas
beaucoup tout cela est-ce que comment
une telle politique ne me ne peut pas
gêner une politique réelle
d'investissement ça c'est une vraie
question dernière question vous avez
pris des positions très avancées sur le
nombre de congp en France en disant
qu'il y en avait trop et un temps de
travail qui était vraiment trop court
est-ce que est-ce que tout cela Monsieur
Drahi est-ce que tout ça monsieur Drahi
est-ce que tout ça monsieur DRI ne peut
pas paraître un petit peu indécent bah
quand on sait la votre fortune
personnelle et tout cela ces salariés
gagnent bien leur argent et méritent
bien leur congé merci merci Martial
Bourquin la parole est à ladislovski
ensuite à Michel Le
merci monsieur le Président oui
président Dra j'ai une seule question à
vous poser et vous avez l'habitude de
voir cette question qui vous a posé la
preuve vous avez commencé votre
intervention en nous parlant de votre
premier emprunt de 50000 € et de votre
endettement francs pardon et de votre
endettement aujourd'hui de 51
milliards monsieur Dr ma question
c'est certes vous êtes très séduisant je
parle pas de votre physique je parle de
votre
discours je parle de votre discours de
votre stratégie et et de vos ambitions
et donc vous savez séduire vos prêteurs
mais d'abord j'aimerais savoir un peu
qui sont-ils comment répartissez-vous
ceux à qui vous vous adressez et
jusqu'où vont-ils vous suivre j'ai bien
compris que vos 51 milliards de dette
sont couverts par une valorisation de
votre entreprise de près de 70 milliards
mais vos ambitions loin vous nous avez
dit que vous avez 2 % du marché
américain aujourd'hui et que vous
itioniez d'avoir assez vite 10 % ça veut
dire beaucoup d'emprunt supplémentairire
jusqu'où vont-ils vous
suivre je pense que vous êtes un de ceux
qui arrivit à le mieux séduire les
groupes bancaires alors j'aimerais
savoir un petit peu qui sont-ils
français européens américains et comment
faites-vous
merci
ladatovski la parole est à Michel
lequarnc ensuite à Dominique Estrosi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président j'entends parler vous entends
parler de beaucoup de milliards je suis
un peu impressionné par je n'ai pas
l'habitude de voir ce que ça représente
exactement on
est je me demande aussi si c'est
l'intérêt de toutes les populations du
monde que vous achetiez toujours
d'autres pour aller où parce que vous
parlez des 10 ans et 20 ans à venir donc
nous on pas trop bien où on va non plus
peut-être que pouvez nous éclairer sur
la route où elle nous mène et nous
sommes attachés beaucoup d'entre nous à
l'idée de service public service public
ça veut dire l'accès de tous et et de
tous les territoires c'est ce qui est
derrière la couverture territoriale
également donc il faudrait tout de même
puisque il y a beaucoup de milliards en
jeu et que on est attaché à cette idée
de République c'est ça la République
c'est l'égalité entre les territoires
est-ce que vous vous pourriez faire un
effort donc pour que les zones rurales
qui sont déjà souvent handicapé par
rapport à l'éloignement des grands
centres urbains et tout il y a un
déficit de culture et tout donc est-ce
que là sur cette ligne là vous pouvez
faire des
progrès parce que c'est ça ça revient
souvent dans nos débats comme quoi ce
n'est pas tout à fait le cas et autre
chose quand vous intervenez dans
beaucoup de pays dans le monde alors là
c'était pour la France mais maintenant
vous intervenez un peu partout vous
faites donc des profits un peu partout
est-ce que par exemple en France la
partie profit réalisé chez nous donne
lieu à des impôts payés en France
puisque c'est une question qui est
souvent posée les
multinationales sont ailleurs
travaillent chez nous il y a des emplois
effectivement mais en même temps il y a
pas toujours l'impôt payé dans le pays
où sont réalisés les voilà ma question
bien merci michelarnc la parole est à
Dominique est ensuite Yan vugrenard oui
merci monsieur le Président je vis vous
poser une question sur le démarchage
téléphonique SFR et sur le podium des
entre ise qui démarche le plus par
téléphone depuis quelques mois il semble
que vous ne maîtrisiez pas forcément la
fréquence d'appel de vos propres clients
et il y a des des mauvais résultats en
matière de satisfaction
client vous seriez dernier des quatre
opérateurs mobiles sur ce dans ce
domaine et premier en terme de plainte
des clients en
2015 alors aujourd'hui depuis le 1er
juin il y a un nouveau service de
démarchage antiéléphonique consommation
ici la loi de consommation 2014
blocketel qui régule le démarchage
téléphonique d'après la presse là encore
SFR je l'ai dit a été remarqué pour ces
méthodes de démarchage répétitive que
comptez-vous faire pour faire est-ce que
vous comptez faire évoluer votre
stratégie au regard de la satisfaction
client bien merci la parole est à
yannique vogrenard ensuite Jean-Jacques
lasser oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Dra vous êtes responsable
économique nous sommes les uns les
autres responsables politiques il y a
pas de différence entre les uns et les
autres sur le fait que nous soyons les
uns les autres du citoyens et donc vous
avez commencé votre intervention en
parlant de de votre origine et de vos
origines et de votre parcours c'est bien
que nous soyons également informés de
tout cela comme le disait un proverbe
africain parfois lorsque tu ne sais pas
où tu vas souviens-toi d'où tu viens ça
peut toujours être utile vous disiez
qu'au début vous aviez commencé avec
50000 1000 francs de de de l'époque la
différence je dirais par rapport à ce
moment-là qui était important où tout a
débuté semble-t-il c'est que lorsque
vous aviez misé sur 50000 francs c'était
seul vous qui étit en cause et quelques
collaborateurs t que maintenant lorsque
vous misez beaucoup plus c'est des
dizaines de milliers de salariés qui
risquent soit d'en bénéficier soit d'en
subir les conséquences donc la vision
doit être un peu différente je veux
rejoindre un certain nombre de questions
qui ont été posées qui vous concernent
en tant que responsable économique
également en tant que citoyen comme nous
la révolution numérique va tout
bouleverser est en train de tout
bouleverser au niveau sociétal voire
même au niveau social également parfois
en terme d'aménagement du territoire et
du coup
comment pensez-vous que cette révolution
numérique va permettre un meilleur
aménagement du territoire à condition
bien sûr on en est tous conscients qu'il
une volonté politique d'aménagement du
territoire mais pas forcément seulement
politique du reste également global et
général et aussi surtout va-t-elle
permettre à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens y compris y compris à celles
et ceux qui sont dans une situation
sociale économique difficile d'accéder à
cette révolution numérique pour éviter
cette fracture sociale et numérique que
nous sommes amenés à constater
quotidiennement enfin vous êtes la 10e
fortune de France la 205e fortune
mondiale et vous avez coutume de dire
que la réussite n'est pas un gros mot ce
qui est vrai la réussite n'est pas un
gros mot donc quel est votre sentiment
par rapport à la différence qui devrait
y avoir entre optimisation F et fraude
fiscale je vous dis cela parce que j'ai
fait partie de laion d'enquête sur la f
des capitaux et ses conséquencescales et
quel moyen la puissance public selon
vous doit mettre en œuvre pour aller
vers plus d'égalité fixal en fonction de
revenus perçus dernier point liberté de
la presse quel est votre conception de
la liberté de la presse monsieur Dra
bien merci Yannick vugrenard la parole
est à jean-jaces lasser ensuite à
Patrick
cha moi je suis ative bien entendu
euh nous n'avons pas nous sénateurs très
préoccupés alors les mêmes questions va
revenir en boucle très préoccupé de
l'aménagement du territoire nous avons
la plupart d'entre nous des
responsabilités dans les collectivités
locales les régions les départements et
j'ai j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment
vous avez commencé à l'évoquer mais
toutes nos collectivités s'engagent
àcore perdu dans les équipements hein
avec plus ou moins de savoir-faire nous
acquéront des compétences internes avec
un peu de chance on y arrive pas trop
mal on a pas toujours de la chance euh
des cabinets d'études qui nous entourent
euh moi je suis convaincu que dans des
affaires comme celles-ci qui qui
demandent la jonction de la volonté
politique sont nos volontés le citoyen
au bout et les compétences que vous
représentez il faut qu'on trouve des
points de rencontre mieux plus clair
mieux clarifiés et je voudrais avoir
votre sentiment sur la notion de
partenariat public privé euh parce que
je pense que c'est dans ces directions
que l'on risque à comm bien à condition
bien entendu que l'on se comprenne bien
sur les objectifs qui peuvent paraître
différents quel est votre point de vue
sur la construction de ces relations
publiques privé et et plus concrètement
alors quel visage cela peut prendre à
l'échelon départemental régional c'est
là que ça va se
passer merci Jean-Jacques lasser la
parole est à Patrick chz et ensuite à
Alain
Durand monsieur le Président Monsieur
Merci de votre présence alors bien sûr
je m'associe à beaucoup de questions on
déjà été posé sur votre positionnement
vis-à-vis des territoires ruraux et je
voudrais rebondir pour cela sur un texte
qui est discuté au Sénat il y a quelques
semaines qui concerne la République
numérique donc j'aimerais avoir votre
vision de ce texte et particulièrement
certains articles qui je sais ont fait
débat au sein des opérateur euh au point
de créer quelques propositions dans le
cadre du comité interméire à la ruralité
il y a quelques quelques jours euh
notamment sur deux points le premier
point c'est la présence de téléphonie
mobile dans nos territoires ruraux je
suis convaincu que les opérateurs n'ont
pas pris conscience du problème et le
minimise donc je voudrais insister sur
ce point-là pour dire que si évidemment
et si on le comprend bien la rentabilité
n'est pas forcément rendez-vous dans ces
secteurs là n'empêche que le service est
indispensable et il y a une
responsabilité collective à ce que les
opérateurs puissent prendre conscience
de de ces sujets et puis deuxème
question je voudrais avoir votre avis
justement sur le maintien ou non des
quatre opérateurs sur la téléphonie
mobile et si dans les mois qui viennent
vous présentez donc des rapprochements
nouveaux sur ces opérateurs puisque il y
a des tentatives j'allais dire qui qui
qu'il qu'ils se font de façon assez
régulière donc j'aimerais avoir votre
position sur ce point merci merci
Patrick la parole est à Alain Durand
ensuite Daniel
grmiller monsieur le Président je
voudrais revenir sur l'aménagement du
territoire B on sait tout ce que et vous
nous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président qu'Internet qui devait être un
service public et bien un service
commercial et vos propos le le
confirment ce matin donc je voudrais
savoir quelle est votre stratégie votre
vision en matière de d'aménagement du
territoire hors zone ami justement par
rapport à à ces zones rurales moins
rentable pour un service commercial
c'est vrai mais des hommes et des femmes
ont décidé d'y vivre et d'y travailler
et donc quelle est cette vision puisque
vous le dites dans vos propos votre
souhait c'est d'investir dans les
réseaux pour densifier la la couverture
on n' pas la prétention d'être ni le
premier ni le second on voudrait
simplement être classé puis deuxième
question en développant votre groupe de
de télécommunication vers les médias
vous présentez là un forfait SFR
presse cette démarche ne risque-t-elle
pas monsieur le Président de faire
perdre de l'argent à l'état français en
faisant bénéficier justement ce forfait
d'un taux de 2,5i % on pourrait l'État
pourrait perdre 1 million d'euros la
France aussi et vous avez déclaré que la
France était
votre merci Alain Durand la parole est à
Danel grémer et ensuite Daniel Dubois
oui merci monsieur le Président
président d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier
d'avoir rappeler un peu votre histoire
et et notamment 81 où vous avez décidé
de prendre des risques et et et de de
vous lancer dans l'économie je l'évoque
parce que ce qui était vrai en 81 est
encore vrai aujourd'hui et il y a des
messages à donner à la jeunesse et pas
qu'aux jeunes mais effectivement
d'entreprendre et doser on en a besoin
dans notre pays et et je pense que j'ai
beaucoup apprécié C cet aspect là j'ai
qu'une question complémentaire à ce qui
a été évoqué n pas du tout parlé de
recherche et développement votre votre
assise et votre développement
aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus basé sur
des acquisition quelle est la part de
votre recherche de développement dans
votre stratégie
aujourd'hui merci Daniel gréiller la
parole est à Daniel Dubois oui président
merci président V merci de de votre
présence vous vous avez anticipé je
crois que vous avez anticipé la
révolution numérique c'est très clair et
donc votre
réussite elle s'appuie naturellement je
r sur cette sur cette anticipation et
cette volonté naturellement d'être
d'être un acteur vous êtes un industriel
euh et et et vous avez dit que dans vos
trois stratégies il y avait
naturellement le réseau la qualité de
service et le contenu euh le contenu
vous pourriez nous en dire un peu plus
parce que le contenu ça peut être des
jeux et du cirque c'est certainement
très rentable mais je direais est-ce que
vous avez aussi une volonté de service
de réel service je dirais au-delà du jeu
je dirais euh pour les habitants je
pense par exemple au scolaires est-ce
que cette volonté là est présente chez
vous et ensuite vous avez acheté New
York vous n'acheterez certainement pas
la veyon
donc non mais je m'excuse pour la Veron
m'excuse pour laavon mais je voudrais
continuer ma question je voudrais
continuer ma questioners collègues donc
le Sénat a créé un fond le fan pour le
développement des structures en milieu
rural est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
l'abonder est-ce que vous êtes prêt pour
qu'il y ait une taxe pour abonder le fan
qui permettra là très certainement de
faire des raisons rural bien merci
Daniel Dubois monsieur le Président
voilà vous avez eu 2 4 6 8 10 12 13
intervenant 14 avec moi parce qu'on est
jamais
13 merci bien d'apporter les réponses à
ces nombreuses questions bon écoutez
merci beaucoup pour toutes vos
questions je vais répondre à toutes les
questions de façon très simple en tout
cas je vais essayer de faire simple et
très
transparente je vais les reprendre dans
l'ordre vous m'en voudrez pas parce que
si je commence à répondre par
d'importance si je la première va être
bien vu puis le dernier va être mal vu
donc je vais me faire des je reprends un
peu dans l'ordre et puis certaines des
questions m' posé on é reposé par
d'autres donc alors premièrement le
ruralz beaucoup parler et vous aviez
terminé par le fan je connaissais pas je
connaissais le fan club je connaissais
le
F commençons par le par le
rural quand j'ai commencé dans le câble
en France
toutes les grandes communes étaient
câblé donc j'avais pas tellement le
choix soit je devais recabler Paris
enfin là le Paris industriel était
impossible ou Marseille ou Lyon soit il
fallait bien que je m'attaque au rest
c'estàdire le rural et leural donc j'ai
attaqué par les grandes villes semirural
c'estàd qu' faisait en moyenne première
convention que j'ai signé c'est la
commune de
châteurenard c'est pas très
grand je crois que la deuxème c'était
ber la troisième c'est Plan d'Orgon donc
là j'allais j'allais de petit de plus
petit en petit vous parliez de laavon je
connaissez bien j'ai fait mes prépas à
Montpellier donc je faisais de la
mobylette dans dans les
territoires et puis et puis j'ai compris
que j'avais besoin de densité mais comme
j'avais pas les grandes villes qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait je suis allé voir les
départements et ben j'ai câblé le
département du rô j'ai câbler le
département de l'héros ça a été
difficile parce que c'était des moments
où personne n'y croyait où euh personne
ne voulait mettre d'argent public donc
il a fallu trouver des des gens qui
portaient un projet au niveau politique
j'ai eu la chance d'en trouver qui pour
certains était d'ailleurs
sénateur je parle par exemple du
sénateur trgouette qui qui a eu qui qui
qui a quand même dès les années 90 vu
que l'avenir CIT la fibre alors que
d'autres pensaient que l'avenir c'était
le
mobile donc on a partagé cette
conviction technologique scientifique et
euh donc dirais les territoires c'est ma
raison d'être au départ s'il avait pas
eu les territoires j'aurais rien fait
dans le câble en France et donc comme
c'était ma raison d'être de départ et
que je je m'appuie beaucoup sur le passé
mes origines
diverses c'est aussi mon avenir et donc
aujourd'hui il est évident que quand on
annonce Michel combe l'a fait récemment
que nous visons 22 millions de foyers
fibrés à l'horizon 2022 si vous
additionnez Paris Lyon Marseille et
toutes les villes de plus de 100
habitants vous y arriverez pas et quand
on annonce 22
millions en fait on voudrait en faire 26
les quatre qui manquent c'est le très
très rural et ce très très rural on peut
pas le faire tout seul d'un point de vue
économique et donc les réseaux
d'initiative publi j'y suis le premier
partisan j'ai câblé toute l'Alsace dans
les années
2000 avec l'aide de certaines communes
avec l'aide du département et avec
l'aide de la région en fonction des cas
par cas d'accord donc
sFR n'a pas été très actif sur les RIP
au cours des trois dernières années mais
vous aurez noté que je ne suis à la tête
des SFR que depuis 1 an
euh mais SFR sera très actifs sur
l'ensemble des nouvelles des nouveaux
projets d'appel à candidature et si on
se présente là c'est pas pour être 2e
c'est plutôt pour gagner à partir de
maintenant donc je suis un partisan très
fort de cette de cette de câblage en
fait de câblage on m'a interrogé sur la
fibre on dit pas le fibrage c'est pas
propre comme mot c'est le câblage avec
de la fibre optique et je réponds à la
question différen câbles fibrees ça me
rappelle les phares jaunes sur les
Renault en France on a deux guerres de
retard en France
minimum c'est le débat c'est un débat
qui n'a lieu qu'en France Portugal
personne me demande câble fibre on s'en
fout ce qu'on ve apporter c'est du giga
à l'abonné la semaine dernière
Numéricable a fait une expérience à 10
Gbit sur son réseau câblé bon c'est quoi
le problème donc là où j'ai du câble je
vends du câble là où j'ai pas de câble
je fais de la fibre forcément parce que
aujourd'hui quand on déploie on va pas
déployer du câble la technologie de
déploiement c'est la fibre alors les
concurrents comme ils ont ni l'un ni
l'autre bah il déploient que de la fibre
forcément puisque eux ils ont un vieux
réseau téléphonique des années 60 pas le
choix ça marchera pas bon donc ça c'est
très simple les débats si vousoulez
technologique bon ça tombe bien je suis
ingénieur bon on peut envie passer la
journée hein si vous voulez ah je
réponds à question sur la r quand j'ai
racheté Portugal téecom j'ai racheté
aussi l'équivalent du du knnet mais
portugais que j'ai pas racheté France
Télécom vous l'z noté donc que j'ai
trouvé 800 chercheurs qu'est-ce que les
gens on dit un investisseur c'est un
financier il a
holdingofshore la notion d'ofshore c'est
quand on habite en France quand onite
pas en France quand compte en Suisse
qu'on habite en Suisse c'est pas de
l'ofshore c'estore juste pour la petite
anecdote donc moi quand c'est quand on
habite en France et qu'on a des comptes
en Suisse que c'est un problème bon je
sais pas qui mais moi c'est pas mon cas
mais en tout
cas le le le le le le problème de la
recherche pour moi c'est pas un problème
c'est une raison d'être j'ai besoin des
ingénieurs aujourd'hui parce que je ne
suis plus moi-même dans les labos j'y
été quand j'avais 20 ans je suis plus
capable d'être dans les labos c'est pas
que j'ai pas envie d'y être je sais que
je peux pas être prix Nobel donc je suis
plus dans les labos ça sert à rien je
peux pas être numéro 1 ou de dans les
labos donc j'ai déjà des Gâts dans les
labos je les garde et il me prévoit ce
qui va se passer dans les 10 prochaines
années et nous exportons aujourd'hui de
la technologie depuis nos labos et j'ai
fait avec Michel combe qui est un
industriel qui a géré comme vous le
savez Alcatel j'ai fait de des centres
de compétences dans différents pays en
fonction des spécificités donc la
recherche et le développement sont au
centre de notre stratégie elle est elle
est globale si j'avais racheté France
Télécom j'aurais mon centre de recherche
en France j'ai pas racheté
France-Télécom j'ai racheté Portugal
téécom donc mon plus gros centre de
recherche est au Portugal c'est pas si
loin c'est très sympathique et les
chercheurs
Portugais sont très compétents on a
tendance en France à estimer les autres
comme moins compétent que nous ne vous
trompez pas la compétence est mondiale
aujourd'hui les Chinois que j'ai vu tout
à l'heure faire du yoga dans le parcuis
le bureau de monsieur le Président sont
très compétents on les a sous-estimé
aujourd'hui dans le mobile moi on m'a
dit il faut acheter français j'achète
français sauf que chinois je m'excuse de
vous le dire ça marche mieux c'est pas
que c'est moins cher son pas moins cher
Alcatel fait les mêmes prix ça marche
mieux c'est triste à dire parler du
réseau de mobile
l'insatisfaction madame stroszi sur mes
clients mobiles en 2015 les clients
insatisfaits en 2015 moi je les ai
récupéré le 30 novembre 2014 donc c'est
pas leur satisfaction c'est pas à mon
égard c'est à l'égard des SFR et
pourquoi ils sont insatisfaits des SFR
en 2015 c'est parce qu'en 2014 en 2013
et peut-être probablement avant sFR n'a
arrêté
d'investir moi quand je rachète SFR le
28 novembre 2014 il a 1 an et 5 mois je
trouve un réseau
sous-investi euh une qualité de service
à l'époque quand on arrivit au à
charles- de Gaulle à l'aéroport qu'on
allait dans Paris le téléphone coupé CIN
fois vous imaginez pour un des
opérateurs qui était le leader en France
alors ne parlons pas dans les
territoires il coupait même pas il
décrochait pas le téléphone bon réseau
sous-investi dans la 3G on parle de 4G
et la génération d'après dans la 3G et
alors n'en parlons pas dans la 4G un T
de couverture quand je reprends SFR de
33 % du territoire national alors que
mes concurrents pour certains loin
derrière en terme de nombre d'abonnés en
terme de chiffre d'affaires en terme de
capacité
financière avait des taux de couverture
de 60 à 70 % donc on était très très
très très mal qu'est-ce qu'on a fait bah
on s'est repoussé retroussé les les
chemises et on a bossé quand on bosse on
n' pas le temps de faire des grands
discours devant les journalistes et on a
pris les plaintes depuis que j'ai
racheté SFR on n jamais reçu autant de
plainte des autorités françaises que
pendant les 20 ans que ça appartenaitre
groupe c'est quand même bizarre parce
que c'est nous qui fais boulot
aujourd'hui et là on est critiqué du
matin peu importe moi la critique ça me
pousse à travailler davantage donc
aujourd'hui nous avons doublé la
couverture en un an nous sommes passés
de 33 à 65% là où les autres sont passés
de 65 à 75 et je pe vous dire que d'ici
la fin de l'année prochaine on sera
numéro donc on y travaille parce que un
client insatisfait pour moi c'est un
client qui m' qui me quitte un client
qui me quitte bah ça me fait mal au cœur
et en plus qu'au cœur au portefeuille
mais d'abord au cœur parce que c'est une
question d'amour propre alors donc les
territoires lancer des appels à
candidature nous serons candidats à
toutes les appels d'offre vous m'avez
titillé sur une ou deux un ou deux
projets où nous ne sommes pas très actif
commercialement nous nous préférons
certains types de projets plutôt que
d'autres types type de projet nous
aimons être propriétairees de nos
infrastructures je préfère être
propriétaire de mes infrastructures que
locataire des infrastructure
euh d'autres personnes même si cette
autre personne est la puissance publique
ça me gêne d'être locataire d'accord
parce que le locataire quelque part
c'est VO quand vous êtes locataire d'un
appartement est-ce que vous allez
refaire la cuisine B vous êes peut-être
changer le papier peint et encore vous
NZ pas refaire la cuisine donc si pour
faaire la cuisine il faut que je demande
à celui qui est le
propriétaire Monsieur laasser m'a dit on
s'entoure parce qu'on est pas forcément
compétent on s'entour de plein de
cabinet de conseil pour essayer d'y
comprendre donc si je dois demander au
propriétaire deaire la cuisine qui sait
pas vraiment comment il faut la faire
qui va demander à 10 personnes comment
il faut faire alors que moi jeis le
faire ça m'ennuie ça me fait perdre du
temps et ça nous vous comme nous mais
surtout vous fait perdre de l'argent moi
je pense que là où par
moment on dépense sans
l'entrepreneur avec ses capacités de
gestion et sa vision et parce que c'est
son entreprise il peut faire mieux pour
moins cher et c'est et c'est ce que je
fais aujourd'hui les investissements de
SFR sont passés de 1 milliard 4 quand on
l'a repris àprès de 2 milliard 3 cette
année en en faisant pas 50 % de plus 1
milliard 4 2 milliard 3 ça fait 50 % en
en faisant trois fois plus parce que
avec le même argent on en fait deux fois
plus ah bah là on est
ouvert
là on est ouvert si on peut reprendre
les infrastructures on est ouvert
d'ailleurs je l'ai fait je l'ai fait en
Alsace j'ai repris des réseaux à
certaines communes voilà bon donc je
réponds je pense à toutes
les je réponds à toutes les questions et
donc vous me disz j'ai acheté New York
on peut racheter l'avyon ben voilà donc
le sujet est ouvert alors vous vous
m'avez interrogé
sur j'essaie de voir un petit peu ah oui
j'ai une question intéressante monsieur
le sateur Bourquin vous disz estce que
le fait fait que mes holdings soient à
l'étranger est incompatible ou
compatible avec les investissements moi
je vais vous dire pourquoi mes holdings
sont à l'étranger d'abord moi j'habite à
l'étranger donc c'estz quand vous
habitez à l'étranger de médecin holding
en France c'est un peu bizarre c'est
comme d'habiter en France et médecin
holding à l'étranger donc moi j'habite à
l'étranger j'ai ma holding à l'étranger
çaez logique la question que vous ariez
dû me poser c'est pourquoi j'habite à
l'étranger alors que j'étais très
heureux en France c'est parce que c'est
très compliqué de faire du business en
France c'est ça la réalité tout à
l'heure vous disiez c'est super tu as
créé ton entreprise et cetera mais je
peux vous dire le parcours du combattant
pour créer une srl au capital de 50000
francs quand on est Monsieur Personne he
et ce parcours du combattant quand j'en
discute tout à l'heure j'en discutais
avec mon chauffeur de taxi on m'a dit
qu'on avait simplifié par c'est encore
plus compliqué qu'en 1991 c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué en 1991 j'arrivais à
faire ma propre fiche de salaire
aujourd'hui
euh je serais incapable même si je me
plongeais dans dans le bouquin pour
faire ma propre alors c'est très bien
pour tous les cabinets pour tous les
cabinets comptables qui font les fiches
de salaire ça crée du boulot là mais par
contre ça crée pas du boulot de rendre
le truc extrêmement compliqué moi
j'arrive à New York par exemple recruter
quelqu'un ça prend 2 minutes pas besoin
de faire 50000 déclarations 50000
organismes qui qui servent pas à
grand-chose en réalité ça prend 2
minutes et puis euh dans l'autre sens ça
prend 2 minutes 30 et ça se passe très
bien parce que la personne comme il lui
faut 3 minutes pour retrouver un nouveau
travail puisqu'il faut 2 minutes pour
discuter une minute pour le trouver tout
ça ça marche bien donc on est entouré de
gens qui sont beaucoup plus simples que
nous nous on est sans doute beaucoup
plus intelligence mais l'intelligence
nuit au sport nuit à la rapidité mettez
un chercheur fou pour avancer vite vous
allez pas y arriver bon l'entrepreneur
c'est le gars qui veut avancer vite pas
lentement donc c'est pour ça que mes
sociétés de tête sont à l'étranger c'est
parce que moi je suis à l'étranger je
suis à
l'étranger alors que je suis rentré de
du Maroc en France
parce que c'était le moment de rentrer
euh c'est que ça la raison alors est-ce
que ça nuit à investir mais juste au
contraire c'est grâce à je répondre à la
question sur l'optimisation fiscale et
la fisc et la frute fiscale qui n son de
notions qui n'ont rien à voir je l'ai un
petit peu dit tout à l'heure quelqu'un
qui habite en France qui a un compte en
Suisse non déclaré c'est de la frutete
fiscale quelqu'un qui habite n'importe
où dans le monde et qui sur la base des
lois fiscales du pays optimise sa
fiscalité bah c'est quelqu'un de malin
mais je pense pas qu'il y a quelqu'un
dans la salle qui quand il remplit sa
déclaration d'impôt essaie de payer plus
que ce qu'il a à payer je crois pas
peut-être s'il veut souscrire au fan
club mais mais c'est un peu la question
parce que la question de l'optimisation
non mais c'est quoi attendez attendez
c'est pas du tout la question mais je
vous ai répondu je vous ai répondu sur
la fraude fiscale et je vous ai répondu
sur mais je je ve reparler de
l'optimisation parce que l'optimisation
c'est une notion mathématique il se
trouve il se trouve que j'en ai fait un
peu pour rentrer à l'X le contraire de
l'optimisation c'est la réduction donc
est-ce que que vous faites votre fil
d'impôt pour payer moins d'impôt non je
connais pas un Français qui en faisant
sa déclaration essaie de gonfler ses
revenus pour payer plus ou pour oublie
de déclarer certains abattements pour
payer plus bon donc l'optimisation dans
les entreprises c'est un métier
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup d'utes de
jeunes dans ce pays qui font des études
dans des écoles des grandes écoles
commerciales et qui choisissent comme
spécialité la fiscalité donc si leur
métier c'était de faire que les
entreprises playent plus d'impôts je
pense qu'il trouverent pas de job donc
les directeurs fiscaux ils sont en
charge de l'optimisation fiscale ils
sont pas en charge de remplir la
déclaration fiscale ça c'est c'est
facile enfin c'est très compliqué ça
change tous les 3 mois mais c'est pas ça
le métier bon alors au contraire si vous
voulez des groupes internationaux comme
les
nôtres ont des capacités
d'investissement bien plus
importantes parce qu'ils sont
internationaux si j'étais resté ici ça
aurait été difficile de faire ce que je
fais il y a certains quand alors je
réponds à une question sur comment je
fais pour lever autant de capitaux je
suis moins bon que le gars qui lève les
capitaux pour la France parce que lui il
enlève plus tous les matins à un taux
plus bas mais pour des chiffres qui sont
moins bons que ceux de mon entreprise si
vous regardez le bilan du pays moi je
préfère mon bilan il est plus sûr donc
quand je lève de alors c'est les mêmes
mes banquers c'est exactement les mêmes
que les vôtres enfin que que ceux de la
France c'est le monde de la finance
alors c'est qui le monde de la finance
c'est des fonds c'est des fonds il y en
a pas tellement à Paris soyons clair ils
sont essentiellement à Londres à New
York à
Pékin un peu partout dans le
monde c'est des fonds qui sont générés
par des personnes physiques
euh qui sont des grands managers des
grands professionnels beaucoup de
Français vous savez que Londres est une
grande capitale française qu'est-ce que
font les Français qui sont à Londres ils
prêtent de l'argent aux Français qui
sont en France hein il prêtent de
l'argent à l'état il prêtent de l'argent
à mon entreprise donc moi quand je veux
contracter un un emprunt je parle pas à
ces gens-là parce qu'ils sont des
milliers je parle à des intermédiaires
ces intermédiaires ce sont les banque
classique que vous connaissez l'un de
mes principals banquiers intermédiaires
mais ce n'est qu'un intermédiaire c'est
la BNP par exemple donc la BNP dit ok
société Altis je vais vous trouver un
emprunt de 1 milliard 2 milliards donc
elle prend un mandat comme un agent
immobilier et va placer ce milliard sur
le marché auprès des gens dont j'ai pas
parler il y a 2 minutes qui sont ces
fonds gérés par des personnes physiques
dont beaucoup sont des Français donc en
fait le monde de la finance c'est un bon
monde parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
Français qui
travaillent il a plus beaucoup à Paris
pourquoi ils sont pas à Paris parce que
on revient à la question d'avant c'est
trop compliqué ça marche pas on y arrive
pas alors le jour où le monde sera
harmonisé mais ça c'est votre job c'est
pas le mien bah tout le monde sera à
Paris ou enfin les gens iront là où
c'est le plus sympa de vivre en en
Verron à Paris à New York au soleil
enfin en fonction des mais entre-etemps
bah les gens ils vont là où c'est le
plus simple et n pas là où c'est le plus
compliqué ça c'est
normal
alors qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas traité
làdedans service public on y a alors
Monsieur le
Député le sénateur estceusez-moi le
squarnc mais vous m'avez
interrogé les services publics j'ai
appris la notion de service public en
1994 en reprenant le réseau de monre et
en négociant avec Monsieur
BR parce que quand j'ai commencé je
signé des conventions avec les communes
des conventions de gré àagé et la ville
de Montreuil vait un service public bon
donc j'ai signé un service public nous
avons équipé à 100 % la commune de
Montreuil les établissements public et
ainsi de suite donc je connais bien
cette notion là et j'y suis attaché
comme vous j'ai des parents professeurs
donc c'est quelque chose
d'important vous m'avez demandé si
l'entreprise SFR payit ses impôts en
France bien sûr et elle en paye beaucoup
et et je dirais grâce ou à cause de moi
grâce à moi pour vous à cause de moi par
rapport à moi-même mais pourquoi elle en
paye beaucoup parce que j'ai rendu
profitable cette entreprise qui neétait
plus et une entreprise profitable en
France paye ses impôts en
France numériqueâ le câble français
croulé sous les pertes et les dettes n'
jamais payé d'impôt de toute sa vie cap
ça a commencé dans les années 78
sénateur roche mes
78 je reprends le câble pas payer impôts
jusqu'en 2008 ou 2009 à partir de 2009
commencer à payer des impôts pourquoi
parce qu'on était
profitable c'est très simple et quand on
fait des profits en France on peut pas
payer ses impôts en Hollande ou au
Luxembourg donc ça c'est ça ça fait
partie du du rêve ou de l'angoisse
collective mais c'est ça la législation
qui s'applique on l'applique comme tout
le
monde je crois que j'ai à peu près tout
couvert comment alors la conso mation ou
lidationationation la
consolidation
euh pour moi elle est pas
indispensable pour mon entreprise elle
n'est pas indispensable je vous l'ai
expliqué la France est très importante
pour nous mais représente un petit peu
moins de la moitié de notre chiffre
d'affaires aujourd'hui
elle est plus indispensable pour ceux
dont la France représente 100 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires dans le
métier donc la question pourquoi ça ne
s'est pas fait bah il faut le demander
au au gens qui ont décidé de pas le
faire mais je pense
que ça n'a pas aidé que que ce soit très
compliqué moi j'avais proposer une
solution simple il y a un an le 3 juin
2015 j'ai mis même le prix sur la
table le premier qui m'a dit non c'est
l'état j'étais très surpris parce que
j'avais cru comprendre oui juste avant
on me dit non publiquement un dimanche
bon donc j'ai arrêter parce que une fois
que l'État dit non c'est pas peine
d'insister mais ce qui est bizarre c'est
que 6 mois après pour le champion
national dont l'état est actionnaire
c'était possible sauf que c'est pas
possible parce que c'était trop
compliqué donc on aurait mieux fait de
prendre ma solution ça aurait été
terminé en 3 mois mais encore une fois
moi j'en ai pas besoin c'est plus pour
les autres alors est-ce que le marché
peut rester comme ça à 4 oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il va rester à 4 pour les 10
prochaines années ça m'étonnerait mais
c'est pas moi qui vais m'activer
là-dessus sur ce dossier ça je vous le
dis
franchement on en a pas besoin ça aurait
été bien je vais vous dire
pourquoi ça auraité bien pour le
consommateur
français parce que
aujourd'hui ben les petits opérateurs
n'ont pas les moyens d'investir beaucoup
et ça aurait été bien pour l'industrie
française à
l'international le champion national
orange fait quelques acquisitions en
Afrique on aurait préféré le voir je ne
sais pas acheter British Telecom tééecom
Italia ENF des gros trucs quoi pas des
petits trucs pourquoi il achète pas des
gros trucs c'est pas parce qu'il a pas
envie c'est parce qu'il peut pas le
faire il peut pas le faire parce que son
marché national qui représente 60 % de
son chiffre d'affaires bah il est pas si
il est difficile alors est-ce que de
vendre à 30 € même en ce moment ça doit
être 14 € là dans la rue j'ai vu tout à
l'heure en arrivant un service qui part
tout ailleurs vaut 80 € est-ce qu'on
doit être fier nous Français de faire ça
moi je pense pas qu'on doit être fier de
brader quelque chose qui vaut quelque
chose c'est pas bon de faire ça surtout
sur son marché domestique euh les
industriels chinois ont réussi en
vendant cher au domestique et en vendant
moins cher à l'international donc ils
ont pu se consolider ou se former une
base saine dans leur pays dans leur base
pour pouvoir déployer à l'international
si nous dans notre base on n pas de quoi
gagner suffisamment d'argent pour
investir à l'international c'est pas
très intelligent après tout à l'heure
j'ai pris un café j'ai déjà raconté
l'histoire la dernière fois mais à
chaque fois que je prends un café ça me
fait le même effet
euh j'ai payé 1,50 € là à côté le café
si je prends un café tous les jours
pendant 30 jours ça fait 45 c'est plus
cher que l'abonnement au très haut débit
pour lequel on investit des milliards il
faut pas faut pas jouer avec ça très
longtemps quand même hein c'est pas bon
pour l'économie voilà
mais on en est là vous m'aviez parlé de
la presse écoutez moi je suis très fier
de ce que j'ai fait pour la presse on
m'a rien demandé j'ai sauvé un premier
titre vous pourrez demander j'ai sauvé
un deuxième titre et j'ai trouvé je
pense un modèle économique pour
l'ensemble de la presse et je pense que
je serai suivi par beaucoup de gens en
intégrant la presse
euh qui était une partie des médias dans
un groupe
télécom c'est assuré la
pérénité un moyen
d'expression vous demanderez aux
rédactions quel est mon niveau
d'intervention zéro euh moi mon niveau
d'intervention c'était de dire ça perd
de l'argent il faut mettre ça à
l'équilibre Point Bar et maintenant
comment on développe comment on
développe ben je peux vous dire que les
titres qui sont disponibles sur
l'application SFR aujourd'hui ben sont
visibles par 12 millions de personnes ça
ve pas dire que 12 millions de personnes
les regardent tous les matins mais des
centaines de milliers les regardent tous
les matins là où ils étaient quelques
milliers il y a il y a 3 4
mois ça c'est important après quelle est
la logique entre la presse et la
télévision bah c'est le numérique c'est
quoi le numérique parce que on a tous
parlé d'internet on se gise avec des
mots dont on comprend pas forcément le
le sens bah l'Internet c'est les
échanges et si c'était que pour échanger
des emails on aurait ou des textos on
aurait pas besoin d'investir dans la 4G
et la fibre la 4G et la fibre c'est
d'échanger la vidéo et la vidéo c'est la
télé donc la numérisation de la presse
c'est la télé donc quel rapport entre
L'Express lib et BFM et ben je en train
de numériser la presse la presse papier
elle existera toujours mais celui qui
fait que de la presse papier moi
j'investirai pas chez lui mais bon donc
voilà tout ça a un sens un sens
économique un sens industrielle
et hier soir nous avons lancé BFM
sport ça fait très longtemps que de
nouvelles chaînes s'est pas lancé en
France nous allons lancer bientôt BFM
Paris dans la continuation de la
réussite du groupe BFM et ça c'est
important de de continuer à avoir des
des médias différents qui sont offerts à
l'ensemble des
clients je crois que j'ai répondu est-ce
que j'ai raté quelques questions
monsieur le Président je n'entends pas
de
n sur la loi pour une république
numérique vous n avez rien dit non
effectivement
alors alors sur le déploiement alors oui
je réponds vous me direz point précis
sur la loi du
NUM
d'accord je pense que les opérateurs que
nous
sommes l'accélération ement de la fibre
par mon concurrent historique que je
respecte beaucoup qui est un très bon
opérateur c'est pas fait parce que le
gouvernement a décrété un plan fibre
c'est fait parce que j'ai accéléré le
déploiement de la fibre en France et
qu'il a essaye de me rattraper ah vous
croyez-moi croyez-moi c'est quand même
bizarre qu'il tire la fibre dans les
rues où nousous l'avons déjà tiré
d'ailleurs je trouve ça incohérent le
déploiement la répartition de la France
aurait dû se aurait dû se faire d'une
façon beaucoup plus cohérente moi
j'arrive sur SFR quand je rachète SFR
moi je suis un opérateur de F j'ajette
un opérateur mobile et je vois que la
zone ami s partagée entre France Télécom
Orange pardon et SFR à hauteur de 20 %
pour SFR de 80 % pour Orange dis tiens
c'est bizarre ça me rappelle le plan
câble ça a pas marcher ça me va pas
parce que en zone dense moi j'ai
d'avance alors pourquoi en zone non
dense France tellcom devrait prendre de
l'avance sur moi j'ai dit 50 50 faisons
ça
correctement donc effectivement SFR
avait arrêté de déployer de la fibre
alors dans les zones on a eu
un accord avec l'autorité de la
régulation dans les zones où nous avions
du câble nous rétrocédions le droit de
déploiement à Orange donc on l'a fait ce
qui nous a valu quelques quelques
discussions dans quelques communes dans
le nord de la France mais sur le reste
je vois pas pourquoi on ferait que 10
millions de prises 8020 on pourrait en
faire 50 50 au lieu d'en faire 100
millions parce que moi je dis pas que je
va investir moins je dis que je vais
investir plus on pourrait faire 15
millions
50 50 donc France Télécom c'est 7
million et dei tel que prévu nous nous
ferions 7 milliion et dei on va venir
tous vous voir dans les terrains sur le
terrain parce que moi je veux fibrer
plus que ce qui m'a été alloué quit à
fibrer en doublon parce que je trouve
que la législation ne me va pas du tout
je ne veux pas être locataire du réseau
des autres je vous l'ai déjà dit tout à
l'heure sur les RIP ça me plaît pas je
préfère autre opérateur d'une
infrastructure que je possède quitte à
avoir des tarifs spécifiques quand il y
a eu évidemment l'invention de l'État ou
des collectivités mais sur le reste en
investissement privé je ne vois pas
pourquoi il y aurait un seul réseau qui
se déploirit et en particulier celui
d'Orange sauf si vous voulez
reconstituer le monopole mais seulement
il faut nous le dire tout de suite ceà
on prendra nos disposition au niveau de
l'entreprise mais je pense pas que ce
soit bon ce qui est bon c'est quand il y
avait le réseau câblé et le réseau de
France téléecom d'ailleurs qui était la
même entreprise c'est quand même bizarre
que quand c'était au sein de France-
telléecom le câble ça marchait pas et
quand je l'ai racheté à France- Télécom
je l'ai fait marcher bon le câble c'est
un moyen d'ailleurs à New York je vous
le signale le réseau câblé à 70 % du
marché le réseau téléphonique 30 % parce
qu'ils étaient indépendants donc le gars
du câble a fait son boulot le gars du
téléphone a fait son boulot résultat des
cours 70 300 en France comme le câble
appartenait à Orange le résultat c'est
8020 dans l'autre sens je suis pas
d'accord donc je propose de faire 50 50
voilà donc les dispositions de cette loi
euh moi ce qui me gêne c'est les
dispositions des lois
précédentes je trouve que le plan fibre
tel qu'il a été articulé ne convient pas
et d'ailleurs les objectifs du Plan
fibre pour la France les 12 millions de
foyers fibrés en 2012 en 2017 c'est
c'est nous qui allons les atteindre
personne d'autre ah si c'est nous qui
allons les atteindre puisqu'on a une
vitesse de déploiement qui nous permet
d'y arriver les autres seront à 3
million derrière à peu
près
voilà non ils seront à 9 orange sera 9
millions de foyers fribrés nous serons à
12 en
2017 bien écoutez monsieur le président
un très grand merci pour votre venue
devant la commission vous avez vu
beaucoup de questions vous ont été
posées il y a eu des des réactions de
part et d'autres par rapport à certaines
des réponses que vous avez apporté en
tout cas à nouveau un très grand merci
d'avoir accepté de venir devant la
commission économique du Sénat merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président merci à
tous pour vos questions voilà pour
l'audition de Patrick Dra le PDG d'Altis
Group et toute autre chose à présent
puisque je vous propose de de voir une
partie du débat des sénateurs à
l'occasion du bilan de l'application des
lois au cours de l'année parlementaire
2015-216 le Parlement a voté 41 lois
c'est plutôt moins que les années
précédentes mais les textes sont de plus
en plus volumineux vous voyez tout de
suite les débats des sénateur qui s'est
déroulé exceptionnellement dans la salle
clémenenceau monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les les présidents
des commissions permanentes chers
collègues rendez-vous désormais annuel
la séance publique de cet après-midi va
nous permettre de faire le point sur
l'application des lois en présence du du
secrétaire d'État chargé des relations
avec le Parlement réitérant l'expérience
de l'an dernier nous avons choisi de
siéger en sal clémenau mieux approprié
que l'hémicycle pour un débat de
contrôle de ce type tous les chiffres de
la dernière session à l'occurrence
l'année parlementaire
2014-2015 figure dans mon rapport écrit
aussi me contenteraije de récapituler
les points essentiels tels que j'en ai
donné un premier aperçu à la Conférence
des Présidents le 11 mai dernier ces
données ont été établies à partir des
bilans détaillés des commissions
permanentes dont je salue la qualité et
les statistiques de la direction de la
législation et de contrôle du Sénat
après recoupement avec les chiffres
concordants du secrétariat général du
gouvernement comme en 2015 nous avons
également eu l'honneur et le plaisir
d'entendre à audition le secrétaire
général du gouvernement monsieur Marc
Guillaume nous avons aussi évoquer avec
lui quelques questions connexes mais
importantes comme la mise en œuvre des
lois d'habilitation ou le taux de
réponse aux questions écrites des
sénateurs au vu de toutes ces
informations je retiendrai cette année
cinq grandes tendances la première tout
d'abord une production législative en
baisse apparente avec 43 lois votées
contre 66 l'an dernier hors convention
internationale mais je dis bien baisse
apparente car en réalité certaines des
lois de l'an dernier ont été de
véritables lois fleuve comportant
plusieurs centaines d'articles à
commencé par la loi Macron avec ses 308
articles ou encore la loi sur la
transition énergétique avec 213 articles
à naval cela veut dire plusieurs
dizaines de décrets d'application qui
espérontle ne viendront pas grver le
des prochaines années presque 30 % des
lois de la précédente session ont été
d'initiative parlementaire comme l'an
dernier le Sénat avec six propositions
de loi a été à l'origine d'environ une
loi sur 7 deuxièmement sur la
législature don depuis le 20 juin 2012
le secrétaire général du gouvernement
nous annoncé un taux d'application de 80
% qui recoupe nos propres calculs et
marque une progression significative par
rapport au précédent exercice le taux
communiqué lors du conseil des ministres
du 11 mars 2016 est passé même à 62 %
monsieur le ministre puisque au 30 avril
2016 et je signale pour mémoire car
suivant la méthode arrêtée de conserve
le gouvernement nous clôturons nos
statistiques au 31 mars de chaque année
pour la seule année parlementaire
2014-2015 le pourcentage de parution des
textes est mécaniquement moindre il
s'élève à ce jour à 62 % en ha de C
point par celui de la précédente session
ces pourcentages appellent de
commentaires tout d'abord que le taux
d'application des lois augmente d'année
en année même s'il reste
perfectible que pour autant ces
statistiques récapitulatives gomme des
écarts parfois sensibles entre les
différentes commissions entre les
ministères et même d'une loi à l'autre
troisièmement autre tendance dans la
durée la résorption progressive du stock
des lois appliquées au point que sur les
120 lois votées depuis le début de la
14e législature quasiment toutes ont
reçu au moins un début de mise en
application concernant les délais de
publication on sait qu'une circulaire de
février 2008 laisse au ministère 6 mois
à compter la promulgation de la loi pour
faire apparaître leur texte l'an dernier
les délet moyens se sont rapprochés de
cet objectif la moy viennent apprécier
sur l'ensemble de la législature
tournant aux alentours de 9 mois et 12
jours c'est plus que prévu certes mais
vu la complexité du processus
réglementaire et la durée incompressible
de certaines consulations je pense au
Conseil d'État j'estime que les
dépassements restent dans la limite du
raisonnable j'aurais par contre aimé
vous dire le taux de présentation des
rapports demandés par le Parlement s'est
amélioré l'an dernier hélas ce n'est pas
le cas car comme les années précédentes
ceutau calculé sur la moyenne des 10
dernières années n'atteint pas 60 %.
faut-il une fois de plus revenir à la
tribune sur ce sujet qui d'année en
année finir par prendre un tour
incantatoire je dirais simplement que
c'est une atteinte manifeste au pouvoir
de contrôle du Parlement dont nous ne
pouvons nous
satisfaire comme je l'ai dit au début de
mon propos outre l'application des lois
proprenes nous avons évoqué plusieurs
questions connexes comme la prise en
compte des positions du Sénat en matière
européenne sur lesquelles le président
Jean biset a publié un remarquable
rapport en mars 2016 ou dans un autre
domaine l'utilisation des lois
d'habilitation de l'article 38 de la
Constitution à ce chapitre et sans
réitérer les développements de mon
rapport écrit je voudrais appeler une
nouvelle fois l'attention du ministre
sur les retards répétés que nous
constatons dans les réponses à nos
questions écrites vous n'en serez pas
étonné monsieur le ministre lequel
d'entre nous ne s'est pas vu obligé un
jour ou l'autre de transformer une
question écrite en question orale au
risque d'encombrer la séance publique
pour espérer obtenir la réponse attendue
en vain au Journal officiel nous avions
déjà évoqué ce problème l'an dernier et
je sais que le président du Sénat en a
récemment saisi le Premier ministre
après la conférence des présidents du 6
avril dernier lors de son audition le
secrétaire général du gouvernement nous
a dit sa détermination à résorber
rapidement le stock des questions
écrites en souffrance ce sera n'en
doutez pas un sujet sur lequel votre
rapporteur reviendra le moment venu en
conclusion je crois légitime de dire que
cette année le bilan de l'application
des lois sans être exceptionnel va dans
le bon sens nous devons en donner acte
au gouvernement surtout la précédente
session confirme la tendance positive
observé depuis 3 ou 4 années elle
relègue peu à peu au rayon des idées
fausses l'affirmation que les lois
serait dans leur ensemble insuffisamment
appliqué c'est un constat irréfutable
dont le Sénat peut se féliciter car par
son action inlassable il a largement
contribué à faire de cette question une
priorité politique
désormais partagé par tous les
gouvernements mais c'est un constat
précaire ne baissons pas la garde car
l'application des lois reste un combat
de tous les instants où doivent se
mobiliser aussi bien les ministères que
les commissions permanente du Sénat
c'est aussi une attente forte exprimée
par nos concitoyens et un gage de
crédibilité de l'action du Parlement car
à quoi bon voter des lois selles doivent
rester lettre mortes je vous remercie
merci euh monsieur le le président pour
euh ce rapport et je vais immédiatement
donner la parole au présidents de de
commission et je vais commencer par le
président Jean-Claude Lenoir pour la
commission des affaires économiques vous
avez la parole monsieur le Président
bien merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la Commission des économiques a eu
l'occasion de m'entendre il y a euh peu
de temps sur euh l'application des lois
qui figurent dans notre portefeuille
d'activité il y a à peu près 30 lois qui
sont sur nos écrans et nous avons
constaté que 11 étaient aujourd'hui
complètement applicable je vais si vous
voulez bien être bref et précis et ne
parler que deux lois majeures que nous
avons eu à discuter ici au Sénat la loi
transition énergétique et la loi
d'avenir agricole pour ce qui concerne
la loi transition énergétique qui
comptait 215 article à l'issue de son
examen parlementaire il renvoie à 180
mesures réglementaires nous avions
entendu pendant les débats la ministre
en charge de l'énergie nous affirmer que
tous les textes réglementaires seraient
pris avant la fin de l'année 2015
aujourd'hui nous constatons à la date du
31 mars qui est la date à laquelle nous
nous référons euh c'est-à-dire 7 mois
après la promulgation de la loi que seul
54 dispositions c'est-à-dire 30 % des
textes réglementaires attendus était
devenu applicable à ce jour le taux
d'application de la loi si on prend
l'ensemble des dispositions s'élève à 48
% 94 mesures et 23 rapports étant encore
attendus nous avons tout à l'heure
monsieur le Président un débat en
science public sur l'application de la
loi transition énergétique et madame la
ministre nous a fait savoir que un
certain nombre de textes ont été
produits par son administration étit
dans les tuyaux en direction du Conseil
d'État en vue d'être un jour signé par
les ministres donc nous prenons Act des
précisions qu'elle nous a apporté malgré
tout il faut souligner que des
dispositions majeures du texte sur la
transition énergétique n'ont pas trouvé
aujourd'hui leur traduction
réglementaire je pense notamment à la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
qui est censée décliner l'évolution du
mix
énergétique dont la présentation
désormais promise pour le 1er juillet
n'a cessé d'être repoussé seul le volet
relatif aux énergies renouvelables a été
publié ces reports successifs souligne
je me permets de le dire ici la
difficulté de la tâche tâche d'autant
plus difficile nous l'avions d'ailleurs
souligné qu'il faut
évidemment que des concessions soient
faites que des compromis soit adopté
malgré tout ce retard pèse sur les
entreprises qui sont directement
concernées
qui sont en face d'incertitude qui pour
l'instant ne sont pas levés à l'opposé
soyons positifs nous pouvons signaler
que des dispositions attendues ont été
prises elles concernent notamment les
les industries
électrointensives le budget carbone la
stratégie bas carbone qui était attendu
par notamment un certain nombre
d'acteurs dont ceux qui appartiennent au
secteur agricole alors il y a eu
d'autres Tex qui ont été publiés
j'anticipe sur la période que nous
examinons depuis le 1er avril je le
signale décret relatif aux travaux
embarqués sur le complément de
rémunération le nouveau cadre
réglementaire des concession
hydroélectrique et la définition des
conditions de mise en œuvre du chèque
énergie néanmoins je tiens à préciser
ici qu'il y a une disposition
réglementaires que le gouvernement
n'entend pas prendre et qui nous
apparaît néanmoins nécessaire concernant
l'installation d'équipement de contrôle
et de gestion active de l'énergie il y a
des accords sur l'appréciation que l'on
porte entre le gouvernement et le Sénat
nous en parlerons ultérieurement la loi
maintenant pour l'agriculture est
applicable à 70 % donc un certain nombre
de dispositions ont été pris
soulignons-le néanmoins les dispositions
qui concernent la protection des espaces
naturel agricole et forestiers le
renouvellement des générations
d'agriculture euh ont certainement fait
l'objet d'une application mais elle est
incomplète et les dispositions relatives
au registrre agricole ne sont toujours
pas applicables de même qu'un certain
nombre d'autres dispositions qui
figureront dans le rapport qui sera fait
ultérieurement je voudrais réserver
quelques instants monsieur le Président
un sujet qui est périphérique mais
important c'est l'usage qui est fait des
circulaires sur le terrain dans nos
territoires les agents des services
déconcentrés appliquent non pas les lois
ni les décrets ni les arrêtés ils
appliquent les circulaires or notre
vigilance doit s'exercer pour vérifier
que les circulaires sont conformes non
seulement à l'esprit mais même à la
lettre des lois que nous avons voté et
des décrets qui ont été pris par le
gouvernement les exemples ne monquent
pas c'est le temps qui me manque pour le
dire mais il y a là un phénomène auquel
le Sénat doit être extrêmement attentif
si nous voulons contrôler d'une façon
totale les applications de lois que nous
avons voter merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président euh la
parole est maintenant à notre collègue
Christian Cambon vice-président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées pour 5
minutes merci monsieur le Président
comme vous le savez l'essentiel de
l'activité législative de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées consiste en l'examin
de projet de loi qui autorise la
ratification des traités internationaux
et ne demande pas de mesures
d'application même si si ces projets ne
sont pas pris en compte dans le contrôle
de la mise en application des lois je
vous informe toutefois qu'au cours de la
session parlementaire
2014-2015 le Sénat a adopté 38
conventions et accords internationaux
relevant de la compétence de la
commission contre 22 au cours de la
session précédente ce qui représente une
augmentation de 72 %. cette nette
augmentation est le fruit d'une
politique volontariste mené en
concertation avec le gouvernement dans
la lignée du rapport Plagnol de
résorption de cette fameuse bosse des
conventions internationales qui étaient
en souffrance d'examens parlementaires
et parfois depuis de longues années ce
qui discréditait un peu la signature de
la France en tant que partenaire
international la Commission a en effet
mis en œuvre une nouvelle méthode
d'examen dite synthétique lorsque le
Sénat est saisi en second d'un traité et
cette méthode porte ses fruits et bien
évidemment tout le bénéfice en revient
aux collègues sénateurs rapporteurs de
la commission qui ont qui se sont prêter
à cette expérimentation laquelle sera
pérénnisée les deux lois promulguées en
2014 2015 dans le secteur de notre
compétence résulte de l'accroissement de
la menace sur le territoire national et
hors de nos frontières c'est la loi de
relative au renforcement de la
protection des installations civiles
abritant des matières nucléaires et par
ailleurs la loi actualisant la
programmation militaire des lois
importantes bien évidemment notre
commission dont le président rafarin
présidait également la déégation au
renseignement en 2015 c'est également
saisi pour avis de la loi de juillet
2015 relative au renseignement fort
logiquement et fort heureusement à la
date du 31 mars 2016 ces lois sont
presque totalement applicables c'est en
particulier le cas de la loi sur les
installation civile nucléaire qu'il a
été en moins de 6 mois avec la
publication de l'unique décret attendu
de même les deux lois de programmation
militaire 2013 et 2015 sont quasiment
totalement applicables en effet sur 20
mesures réglementaires il ne manque
actuellement qu'un seul arrêté pour
celle de 2013 et pour 2015 c'est un peu
moins bien il manque encore trois
mesures d'application sur C la
commission conclu que lorsqu'il y a une
volonté politique forte le travail
réglementaire se fait sur ces sujets le
Sénat a soutenu le gouvernement en
votant largement ces textes dans des
délais d'examen brefs la Commission se
félicite donc que l'impulsion ne se soit
pas arrêté à la porte du Parlement est
été maintenu au-delà en se diffusant au
sein des services de l'administration
quand on veut on peut même s'il reste un
petit effort à faire en effet parmi les
lois adoptées au cours des sessions
antérieures la loi du 28 juillet 2011
sur les réserves militaires et civiles
est enfin devenue totalement applicable
avec la publication très attendue du
décret en Conseil d'État du 7 mai 2015
qui a précisé les modalités
d'utilisation des réserves civiles et
militaires dans le cadre du dispositif
de réserve de sécurité nationale pour
autant ce sujet connaît une nouvelle
actualité une nouvelle actualité depuis
les déclarations du président de la
République au Congrès le 16 novembre sur
la garde nationale et nous risquons donc
de voir ce chantier rouvert alors qu'en
fait nous venons à peine de le clôturer
s'agissant du dépôt des rapports
demandés par le Parlement notre
commission n'est pas totalement
satisfaite comme le fait remarquer le
Président berrybat dans son rapport nos
remarques sur les transmissions tardives
ou lacunaires de rapports sont toujours
un peu
incantatoires je me contenterai donc de
vous faire part du principal regret de
notre commission celui de ne pas avoir
reçu encore le bilan annuel politique
opérationnel et financiers des
opérations extérieures en cours prévu à
l'article 4 de la loi de programmation
militaire sur les quatre rapport prévu
par ce texte c'est le seul qui n'est pas
encore été déposé or c'est un de ceux
qui revait le plus grand intérêt la
Commission a donc décidé de faire
elle-même son propre bilan des OPEC
c'est l'objet d'une mission qu'elle a
confié à nos collègues Jacques Gautier
et Daniel Renner à l'inverse nous
souhaitons souligner que le gouvernement
a déposé avec quand même de mois de
retard le rapport sur l'émission des
forces armées sur le territoire national
en protection des populations ce rapport
a été jugé par la commission insuffisant
sur le plan de la doctrine d'emploi des
forces mais il a toutefois permis un
échange fructueux avec le gouvernement à
l'occasion d'une déclaration suivie d'un
débat en séance publique la commission
s'était auparavant rendue sur le terrain
auprès des soldats de l'opération
sentinelle pour préparer ce débat et
notre critique constructive notamment
sur le caractère trop statique des
gardes ou l'insuffisance autonom
l'insuffisante autonomie par rapport aux
forces de sécurité intérieure a conduit
à des modifications du dispositif c'est
encore insuffisant mais nous considérons
que c'est un début il y a donc bien des
rapports utiles qui sont lus qui sont
débattus et qui sont même suivis des
faits en conclusion monsieur le
Président et sous les réserves évoquées
notre commission dresse un bilan
globalement positif de l'application des
lois relevant de son se
pour la session 2014 2015 merci Monsieur
con le même est est révélateur mais de
bonheur bien la parole est maintenant au
président Alain Milon président de la
commission des affaires sociales oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour la
commission des affaires sociales le
bilan de l'application des lois porte
certain sur un nombre de textes assez
réduit plusieurs lois examinées par la
Commission 2014-2015 étaient
d'application directe d'autres ont vu
leur discussion se poursuivre sur la
session suivante pour les lois entrant
dans le périmètre de ce bilan annuel 144
mesures d'application était attendu au
31 mars 2016 96 était intervenu soit un
taux de 67 % c'est moins satisfaisant
que l'an dernier où nous avions atteint
un taux de 78 % sur un nombre beaucoup
plus important de mesures attendu
puisque ce nombre était de 265 je
voudrais tout de suite tempérer cette
appréciation car de depuis le 31 mars
plusieurs textes attendus ont été
publiés et le taux de mise en
application a donc sensiblement
progressé pour la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2015 le décret
instaurant pour les hôpitaux de
proximité un financement mixte combinant
la tarification à l'activité et une
dotation forfaitaire apparu il y a 15
jours nous nous en félicitons car il
s'agissait d'une proposition de la Meex
du Sénat formulée dans son rapport sur
la T2A mais formulée en 2012
en revanche nous regrettons que
plusieurs dispositions censé renforcer
l'efficience des prises en charge par
l'Assurance Maladie demeur non appliqué
c'est le cas par exemple des dotations
pour l'amélioration de la qualité de
soins dans les établissements de santé
ou de la régulation de l'offre des taxis
conventionnés pour le transport des
patients de même le Sénat avait prévu
une procédure d'achat groupé de vaccins
au profit des établissements de santé et
des centres de vaccination relevant de
collectivités territorial de ité locale
nous regrettons là aussi l'absence de
décret d'application s'agissant de la
loi relative au dialogue social et à
l'emploi dite loi repsamen 52 %
seulement des mesures attendues étaient
prises au 31 mars le retard a en partie
été comblé ces derniers mois avec la
parution de plusieurs textes qui porte
désormais à 75 % le taux de mise en
application parmi les mesures en attente
figure celle permettant la conclusion
d'accords collectifs dans les
entreprises dépourvu de représentation
syndicale l'article 21 et le décret
d'application de l'article 26 sur les
services de santé au travail il est vrai
que sur ces deux sujets le droit n'est
pas stabilisé puisque nous en discutons
à nouveau dans le cadre du projet de loi
travail de manière générale
l'intervention en fin de législature
d'un texte touchant à de multiples
aspects du droit du travail conduite à
revenir sur des mesures de lo lois
antérieure avant même qu'elles aent pu
pleinement entrer en application cela ne
peut qu'alimenter une critique
régulièrement formulé en droit du
travail notamment celle de l'instabilité
de la législation notre commission a par
ailleurs été chargé du suivi de la mise
en œuvre du volet social de la loi pour
la croissance l'activité et l'égalité
des chances économiques soit près de 80
articles sur les 308 de cette loi dans
le champ des affaires sociales 77 % des
mesures attendues était intervenu fin
mars taux qui s'est lui aussi amélioré
depuis avec l'pparution de nouveaux
textes nous constatons que ce texte
promulgué il y a 10 mois a fait l'objet
d'un effort tout particulier pour
permettre sa mise en œuvre effective
dans des délais plus rapides que ceux
auxquels nous sommes habitués peut-être
faudrait-il s'inspirer du dispositif
mise en place pour ce qui nous paraît
aujourd'hui exceptionnel deviennent
demain habituel pour les lois
antérieures à octobre 2014 le décret
permettant l'application de la loi du 6
décembre 2013 sur l'expérimentation des
maisons de naissance issue de la
proposition de loi déposée par mugaddini
est enfin intervenue l'arrêté fixant la
liste des neu maisons de naissance
autorisées à fonctionner de manière
expérimentale a été publiée moins de 2
semaines avant le terme fixé par la loi
pour lancer
l'expérimentation de même a été publié
Journal officiel il y a 15 jours il y a
15 jours l'arrêté imposant une teneur
maximale en sucre ajouté au produit
exclusivement destiné à l'outreem prévu
par la loi du 3 juin 2013 notre collègue
Michel Vergo rapporteur du texte était
vivement intervenu d'ailleurs à ce sujet
en commission le mois dernier la
question est désormais réglée mais nous
comprenons mal la justification d'un tel
retard pour conclure il me paraît utile
de souligner le réel effort réalisé sur
une grande majorité des lois pour
publier les textes d'application dans
des LD relativement raisonnables mais
lorsque je constate d'une part que 3
mois seulement se sont écoulés entre le
dépôt de la loi du repsamen sur le
dialogue social et son son adoption par
le Parlement et d'autre part que 8 mois
plus tard la moitié seulement des
décrets d'application avaient été pris
il m'a paraît que ce n'est pas toujours
la procédure parlementaire qui s'avère
la plus longue et la plus problématique
il y a donc encore des efforts
collectifs à réaliser pour permettre
l'application rapide des décisions
politiques merci merci euh monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant à
Madame Catherine main de Sailler
présidente de la commission de la
culture de la communication et de
l'éducation pour 5 minutes vous avez la
parole merci Monsieur le le Président
Monsieur le MIN mes chers collègues au
cours de de cette session quatre lois
ont été promulgué dans les secteurs de
compétences de notre commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication je vous les les rappelle
la loi de décembre 2014 habilitant le
gouvernement à prendre les mesures
relevant du domaine de la loi nécessaire
pour assurer en droit interne le respect
des principes du code mondial
antidopage la loi du 20 février 2015
portant diverses dispositions
d'adaptation du au droit de l'Union
européenne dans les domaines de la
propriété littéraire artistique et du
patrimoine culturel d loi d'adu la loi
du 17 avril 2015 portant diverses
dispositions tendant la modernisation du
secteur de la presse enfin 4e loi la loi
du 25 juin 2015 portant transformation
de l'Université des Antilles et de la
Guyane en Université des Antilles
ratifiant diverses ordonnances relatives
à l'enseignement supérieur à la
recherche et portant également diverses
dispositions relatives à l'enseignement
supérieur sur un plan strictement
numérique on notera que la liste des
lois promulguées dans les secteurs de
compétence de notre commission traduit
une stabilité de son activité
législative sur ces quatre lois
promulguées quelques remarques une est
issue d'une proposition de loi déposée à
l'Assemblée nationale par Monsieur Bruno
lerou et plusieurs de ses collègues il
s'agit de la loi relative à la
modernisation du secteur de la presse
deux lois sont d'application directe il
s'agit de la loi sur le code mondial
antidopage et celle sur l'université des
antis et de la Guyane en revanche deux
autres lois nécessitent des décrets
d'application ainsi aujourd'hui la loi
que j'ai précité à la relative à la
modernisation du secteur de la presse
est partiellement applicable de décret
sur trois ayant été pris et la loi sur
le Dadu est devenue totalement
applicable puisquil y avait qu'un seul
décret qui met en application trois
disposition euh voilà alors ayant dit
cela euh on peut dire que le constat que
nous avons effectué les années
précédentes se confirment c'est que le
choix de la procédure accélérée
et sans incidence sur le rythme de
parution des mesures d'application de la
noix et j'ajouterai que il vaut mieux
car rien que pour cette session toutes
les lois promulguées ont fait l'objet
d'une procédure
accélérée le contrôle de lapparution des
textes d'application renvoie évidemment
à la question des des délais qui a déjà
été évoqué par les précédents orateurs
et nous notons également que desefforts
ont été accomplis par les gouvernements
successifs et un texte de loi
s'accompagne désormais d'un calendrier
de parution des mesures d'application ce
qui est satisfaisant le délai de
parution des décrets d'application donc
pris au cours de la période qui s'étend
du 1er octobre 2014 au 31 mars 2016 pour
les lois promulguées au cours de l'année
parlementaire est inférieure à 3 mois
dans la moitié des
cas pour terminer ce panorama de de
contrôle je ferai quelques remarques sur
les rapports qui sont demandés dans les
textes de loi des rapports demandés au
gouvernement leur dépôt laisse toujours
apparaître un retard les gouvernements
successifs ne manifestent que peu de
volonté en tout cas de motivation à leur
égard et le nombre de rapports en
attente de parution demeure
particulièrement élevé un chiffre 36
rapports depuis 2000 14 reports 14
rapports sont parus au cours de la
session
2015 enfin un point dont on peut se se
satisfaire la plupart des textes
attendus pour l'application des grandes
lois votées depuis le début de la
législature dans les secteurs qui
relèvent de la compétence de notre
commission sont désormais
parus deux des lois promulgué au cours
de précédentes sessions sont entré
totalement en application au cours de
l'année parlementaire 2014-215 il s'agit
je vous le rappelle de la loi relative à
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
le dernier décret d'application est paru
en avril 2015 et il s'agit également de
la loi relative à la refondation de
l'école dont les deux derniers décrets
attendus sont parus au cours de la
session c'est l'arrêté du 3 novembre
2015 sur la périodicité et le contenu
des visites médical et de dépistage
obligatoire et le décret du 31 décembre
2015 relatif à l'évaluation des acquis
Scola des élèves au livret scolaires à
l'école et au collège en revanche et
sera mon dernier mot le bilan
d'application des lois anciennes reste
très mitigé les décrets parus pour la
période de référence ne concernent ou à
de rares exceptions près les lois
promulguées lors des législatures
antérieures voilà mes chers collègues le
bilan que fait notre commission pour
cette session
2014-205 merci madame la Présidente la
parole est au président Hervé Moret
président de la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues le bilan
de l'application des lois suivies par la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
fait lui aussi apparaître les grandes
tendances mises en avant par les autres
commissions du Sénat à savoir une
amélioration dans la mise en application
des lois avec une progression de la
plupart des indicateurs qui permettent
d'en rendre compte un délai moyen devenu
plus raisonnable pour lappution des
décrets d'application et un point noir
qui a déjà été souligné le taux
nettement insuffisant de remise les
rapports demandés par le Parlement au
gouvernement cette année nous relevons
trois points
positifs le premier la la loi du 1er
octobre 2014 relative au taxis aux
voitures de transport avec chauffeur
seule loi promulguée relevant de nos
compétences cette année a été
entièrement et rapidement appliqué par
le gouvernement c'était nécessaire et
nous nous en félicitons autre motif de
satisfaction l'amélioration du taux
d'application des lois plus anciennes
suivies par la commission avec la
publication de 18 décrets en Conseil
d'État 8 décrets simples 16 arrêtés et
une ordonnance c'est nettement plus
satisfaisant que l'année dernière où
nous n'avions observé que 15 mesures
d'application enfin mais c'est la
moindre des choses aucune des lois
suivies par notre commission depuis 10
ans n'est aujourd'hui totalement
inapplicable chacune d'elles a fait
l'objet d'au moins une mesure
réglementaire d'application voilà donc
pour les points positifs mais comme les
années précédentes plusieurs motifs
d'insatisfaction demeurent et j'en
développerai deux le premier près du
tiers des lois relevant des domaines de
compétence de la commission attendent
encore une ou plusieurs mesures
d'application sur les 36 lois suivies
dans le cadre de notre bilan 10 sont
encore que partiellement applicables et
la moitié d'entre elles seulement a fait
l'objet d'une nouvelle mesure
d'application au cours de la période
c'est évidemment
insuffisant de même nous déplorons cette
année encore la lenteur de remise des
rapports demandés au gouvernement au
cours de l'année parlementaire
2014-2015 seuls trois rapports
intéressant notre commission ont été
déposés au Sénat une illustration de
cette lenteur le rapport sur les impacts
de l'autorisation de circulation des
poid lourds de 44 tonnes daté du mois de
mai 2015 par ses auteurs il n'a été reçu
à la commission que le 9 mars 2016 alors
que la loi exigait sa remise avant le 31
décembre
2014 je voudrais également avant de
terminer mon propos insister sur
quelques texes emblématique suivi par
notre commission je réserverai au débat
prévu à la suite de celui-ci mes
commentaires sur la loi relative à la
transition énergétique d'autant plus que
Jean-Claude Lenoir en a en a parlé je
voudrais insister sur deux textes la loi
du 1er octobre 2014 relative au au taxis
aux voitures de transport la publication
de l'ensemble des des mesures
réglementaires a été comme je l'ai
indiqué effectué rapidement et a donc ce
texte a donc été rendu totalement
applicable ce qui est un point positif
nous avons même eu la satisfaction
d'obtenir le rapport qui avait été
demandé mais malheureusement celui-ci ne
comportte pas tous les éléments qui
étaient demandés notamment à l'article 3
où nous attendions des éléments
concernant l'évolution de l'offre de
taxis dans les métropoles et des
propositions de pistes de réforme
concernant la procédure de délivrance
des
autorisations deuxème loi importante si
la quasi-ttalité des texes réglementair
d'application ont été pris en ce qui
concerne la loi du 4 août 2014 portant
réforme ferroviaire il reste encore
trois dispositions importantes et très
sensibles que nous attendons en premier
lieu et c'est malheureusement
d'actualité le décret socle inscrit à
l'article 17 qui doit fixer les règles
relatives à la durée du travail dans les
entreprise ferroviaire et
d'infrastructure un projet de décret a
été transmis au Conseil d'État au mois
de mars mais sa version définitive doit
impérativement être publié avant le 1er
juillet date à laquelle le régime de
travail actuel deviendrait caduc il y a
donc mes chers collègues urgence au-delà
des textes réglementaires d'application
il faut également signaler le retard
pris dans les conclusions des contrats
cadres devant être signalé entre l'État
et les trois épiques du groupe
ferroviaire d'autre part or ces contrats
performance sont déterminants pour que
l'État exerce effectivement son rôle
d'État stratège et que la et que la
trajectoire financière de ces épiques en
particulier celle de SNCF réseau soit
davantage maîtrisé et prévisible ces
contrats ne seront vraisemblablement pas
conclus avant l'année 2017 ils doivent
être précédés d'un rapport stratégique
d'orientation dont le Haut Comité du
système de transport ferroviaire n'a
toujours pas été destinataire je
terminerai en évoquant la la loi
emblématique du 17 décembre 2009
emblématique en terme de non respect de
la volonté du législateur cette loi
relative à la lutte contre la fracture
numérique à un taux d'application qui
n'évolue pas et notamment le décret
devant fixer les conditions
d'attribution euh des aides du fond
d'aménagement numérique du territoire et
surtout l'alimentation de ce fond n'a
toujours pas été pris et ne le sera
vraisemblablement jamais puisque le
gouvernement a fait le choix de mettre
en place un autre dispositif celui du
fond pour la société numérique et je ne
peux que regretter ce choix qui marque
une volonté délibérée de la part des
gouvernements successifs de ne pas
respecter la volonté du législateur je
vous remercie merci monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant à
madame la Présidente Michel André pour
la commission des finances madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
à mon tour je commencerai par quelques
chiffres nous attendions 106 mesures
83 sont parus soit 80 % mais seulement
40 % des mesures attendues sont paru
dans le délai réglementaire de 6 mois
les lois de finances sont toujours voté
dans délai très brefs il est dommage que
les mesures d'application ne soient pas
soumise à un calendrier aussi serré nous
contrôlons l'application des lois votées
par le Parlement mais la législation
financière se fait de plus en plus par
ordonnance en particulier lorsqu'il
s'agit de transposer des directives j'ai
constaté que si h projets de loi ont été
déposé pour ratifier les 10 ordonnances
prises sur le fondement des
habilitations données par la loi d'adu
de décembre 2014 aucune ordonnance n'a
été ratifiée à ce jour l'une d'entre
elles le sera bientôt celle qui
transpose en droit français tout le
dispositif de l'Union bancaire du
mécanisme de résolution unique et de la
garantie des dépôts la procédure retenue
a été celle d'un amendement déposés par
le gouvernement au projet de loi Sapin 2
nous contrôlons aussi la remise des
rapports demandés par le gouvernement et
je voudrais rappeler que ce n'est pas
toujours pour le plaisir ou pour
contourner l'article 40 que les
parlementaires de demande des rapports
mais parce qu'il considère que les lois
ou les politiques publiques doivent
faire l'objet d'évaluation afin d'être
si besoin amélioré nous travaillons
beaucoup cette année à la commission des
finances sur les questions de fraude
d'évasion ou d'optimisation fiscale
internationale et le projet de loi 10
sapin 2 que nous examinerons bientôt
nous amènera à poursuivre notre effort
puisqu'il comporte des dispositions qui
transportent dans notre droit interne
des recommandations du projet BEPS de
l'OCDE à cet égard il nous aurait été
particulièrement utile
de bénéficier depuis le début de l'année
des deux annexes au projet de loi de
finance relatives pour l'une au
fonctionnement de notre réseau de
convention fiscale et pour l'autre à la
mise en œuvre par l'administration
fiscale des divers outils permettant de
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale des
multinationales nous avons interrogé
publiquement le ministre du Budget des
représentants de l'administration
fiscale qui nous ont promis ces
documents dans les meilleurs
délis nous attendons encore à l'inverse
il arrive que des rapports fourn niss
des informations utiles au travail
législatif la loi de 2014 sur les
comptes bancaires inactifs et les
contrats d'assurance vie en désérance
prévoyait à la demande du Sénat la
remise du rapport en mai d'un rapport en
mai
2016 une lecture attentive de ce
document nous a permis au rapporteur
général et moi-même d'identifier des
difficultés dans la mise en œuvre de
cette loi dont certaines ne pourront
être résolu que par de nouvelles
modifications législatives ainsi le
montant cumulé des contrats collectifs
de retraite non réglé après la cessation
d'activité du bénéficiaire est
particulièrement élevé jusqu'à 7
milliards d'euros selon les estimations
de la CPR cela montre que le phénomène a
été fortement sous-estimé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je conclurai en constatant
de manière assez banale que l'absence de
publication des mesures réglementaires
peut porter préjudice à la mise en œuvre
de réformes attendues à 3 jours du début
de l'Euro je ne prendrai qu'un seul
exemple celui de l'article 67 de la loi
de fin finance pour 2015 qui a réformé
la taxe de séjour et à la suite duquel
un décret a prévu la publication le 1er
juin et le 31 décembre d'un fichier
informatique reprenant les informations
relatives à la taxe de séjour dans
toutes les communes l'ayant instauré il
s'agit notamment de permettre aux
plateformes de type Airbnb qui peuvent
désormais collecter la taxe de séjour
pour le compte des logeurs de mettre en
place ce système de manière simple pour
chaque commune sans avoir à se procurer
toutes les délibérations une à
aujourd'hui rbnb ne collecte la taxe de
séjour qu'à Paris et à Chamonix les
modalités de ce fichier doivent être
précisé par un arrêté qui n'est toujours
pas paru par conséquent les communes ne
bénéficieront pas autant qu'elles
l'auraient pu des recettes lié à
l'organisation de l'Euro 2016 afin de
limiter les inconvénients de cette
situation le ministère de l'Intérieur a
toutefois mis en ligne les délibérations
scannées des communes qui les ont
transmises voilà monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues les quelques
observations que je voulais formuler et
je voudrais remercier particulièrement
le président président du Sénat et le
vice-président Claude Berry debas de
leur investissement en faveur de la
bonne application des mesures votées par
le Parlement merci madame la
Présidente la parole est au président
Philippe B pour la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation du
suffrage universel du règlement et
d'administration générale l'ensemble
d'intitulé montre bien l'étendue de vre
commission monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègue je veux
tout d'abord saluer le rapport de notre
collègue le président Berry débat très
instructif très complet et si complet
qui me permettra pour ce qui me concerne
d'être concis en ne revenant pas sur le
détail des de tous les textes au vu du
bilan que nous avons établi pour la
commission des lois il reste à mes yeux
de très importantes marges de progrès
pour assurer la bonne application des
lois nous avons bien sûr enregistré
serait déjà des progrès mais l'objectif
annoncé depuis 2012 d'un taux
d'application des lois de 100 % 6 mois
après leur promulgation
est loin d'être atteint puisque en 2014
2015 75 mesures pour des mesures
réglementaires prévues ont été prises
alors c'est toujours l'affaire du verre
au 3/4 vides et ou au quart plein là il
reste tout de même un quart des mesures
et à prendre ce qui est beaucoup en fait
beaucoup trop euh un tel taux doit en
plus être fortement nuancé parce que il
y a l'aspect qualitatif des mesures
prises c'est plus difficile à évaluer
bien sûr et puis il y a un certain
nombre de mesures secondaires euh et
puis 6 mois après la fin de la session
il y a toujours des mesures qui ne sont
pas prises le recours à la procédure
accélérée n'est d'ailleurs pas sans euh
h poser la la question du rapport entre
le recours à cette procédure accélérée
et la vitesse d'application des textes
euh il s'est particulièrement intensifié
cette année il faut le remarquer son
usage était moins fréquent lors des deux
sessions précédentes il est nettement
reparti à la hausse euh dans la période
récente euh près de près de 80 % des
textes promulgués au cours de la session
ont fait l'objet d'une procédure
accélérée et en réalité 91 % des projets
de loi et fait à à souligner également
57 % des propositions de loi euh on peut
comprendre que le recours à cette
procédure euh puisse être justifié
parfois par l'urgence qu'il y a à
légiférer mais euh forceé de constater
que désormais son utilisation est
devenue quasi
systématique euh et je dirais dans un
instant euh combien euh le bref délai
laissé au législateur pour légiférer euh
n'est pas accompagné dans un certain
nombre de cas d'une même célérité de la
part du gouvernement pour appliquer les
textes ainsi
délibéré je vais revenir euh plutôt que
de revenir je le disais à l'instant sur
tous les textes sur plusieurs points que
je voulais particulièrement souligner il
y a d'abord la loi du 16 février 2015
elle est relative à la modernisation et
à la simplification du droit pour faire
cours elle a abordé un très large
éventail de sujets touchant au droit
civil à la procédure pénale et bien les
dispositions réglementaires pour cette
loi de simplification sont peu
nombreuses l'administration n'a pas de
hâte à appliquer les lois de
simplification on peut le remarquer à
l'examen de la situation d'application
de cette loi plusieurs des dispositions
de cette loi avait été jugé inapplicable
par le Sénat et il se trouve que elles
n'ont pas été appli qu alors on peut
aussi se dire que les difficultés
d'application devraient réagir rétroagir
sur notre manière de légiférer et que
parfois il y aurait intérêt à être plus
attentif aux mises en garde énoncé par
les rapporteurs du Sénat la question se
pose notamment pour la réforme de
l'enseignement des auto-écoles nous
avions souligné qu'il y avait pas de
pertinence à faire former des candidats
au permis de conduire par des maîtres
qui n'avaient pas eux-mêmes achevé leur
formation on n'a pas réussi à trouver la
disposition d'application de cette
nouvelle règle euh la création d'un
tribunal foncier en Polynésie française
même chose on se demandait comment le
représentant du gouvernement de la
Polynésie française pourrait intervenir
dans chaque affaire de terre bien pour
l'instant il n'intervient dans aucune
puisqu'on n' pas réussi apprendre le
décret d'application je dir un mot aussi
de la loi sur le renseignement
euh le temps parlementaire et le temps
exécutif euh n'est pas à la faveur du
temps exécutif pour l'application de
cette loi les textes réglementaires ont
été beaucoup plus longents à intervenir
que la cadence à laquelle nous avons dû
conduire ce débat heureusement tous les
décrets aujourd'hui sont pratiquement
publiés dernier point les aspects
qualitatif il arrive qu'une dynamique
d'application des lois seée qui s'écarte
des objectifs poursuivis par le
législateur non pas à partir de textes
réglementaires mais du fait d'une
doctrine d'application mise en œuvre par
les préfets c'est le cas en particulier
pour l'application des dispositions de
la loi relative à la nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
République en ce qui concerne les
intercommunalités quand les arrêtés de
périmètre prévoient en zone rurale le
regroupement de plus de 50 ou 100
communes voire davantage alors que la
loi n'a prévu aucun instrument juridique
pertinent pour permettre le bon
fonctionnement de teles
intercommunalités le résultat c'est que
le législateur devra de nouveau
intervenir pour appor apporter des
solutions indispensables à ces
difficultés essentielles d'ailleurs dans
le domaine de la démocratie locale voilà
pour ce débat qui s'est déroulé à
l'occasion du bilan de l'application des
lois avec notamment l'intervention vous
l'avez entendu du rapporteur le sénateur
socialiste Claude Berry debas vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances et toutes les auditions sur
notre site publicsenat.fr très bonne
journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires